This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Wow.
Christina Catholic.
It's sexy.
That's a deep, who is that?
That was um, content. My jeans,
jeans in my kinds in my account.
I know, but the guy that made it,
he's an actual music. It's not in
this uh, gosh, he's so good too.
He used to send him bang.
This is one of the original,
it's the old school stuff.
If you haven't been deep in the vaults,
you wouldn't know jeans in
my car. But that's it. Um,
and it's a great way to start off the
new year. Happy new year, everybody.
Nappy hairs, everyone. We're recording
this out of sequence so we have to, um,
we're kind of banking some episodes for
stuff we have going on. This should be a,
if everything goes well,
God willing and Shiela,
we'll be doing our next phase,
allot x next episode in the
new space and the new studio,
which we're really excited.
Yes. Yeah. I mean, listen,
we haven't really spoken
about it too much at length,
but this is going to be a
pretty great change for us.
I'm excited for you guys to sound asleep.
It's a dream come true.
You know how long I've been like, you
know, uh, I've been wanting to do this.
And then you were like, go ahead,
do your thing, do your move. Well,
I'll tell you what happened is that
you kind of wore me down. I was, yeah,
I was in my last trimester of pregnancy
with our second child and I was like,
I was shooting the special for Netflix.
I was already exhausted and,
and you were like, I want to
build the studio. And I'm like,
right now we're just
about to have a second. We
have this great home studio.
What the heck is wrong with you?
And then you just kept wearing me
down like a guy. It's like a guy,
like we're talking about a few
episodes ago. Just the tip.
Let me just put the tip and see how
that feels. Just, it feels good. Yeah.
And I won't put it any more. And
that's right. And you kind of like,
well let me just,
let me just research the spaces.
And then you started to go look at
spaces with our real estate person or
whatever. And I was like,
okay, that's the tip.
I realize that then that the tip
was already in and then you're like,
I found this amazing space. He's showing
me the pictures and then you're, you're,
you're all weigh in. Yeah. And I was
like, just go for it. Just finish this.
Hey, I mean, wait till you guys see it.
You'll hopefully see it next week. I mean,
we didn't hold back.
We want it to do,
we'll try and we went full throttle
on the new space. But I mean in all,
in all facets of it. Um,
full trocar is the set,
the audio, there's an audio, you know,
I've always been like, all right,
I hate when any audio thing goes.
You know, we have compressors,
we have a whole new set up there
with, with design, a new video,
new lighting.
You want to talk lighting.
Our guy who did our lighting
left as he was setting up
our lighting because a,
a certain president Hw Bush died. Right?
And he's like, oh, I got to go like that.
Okay.
He lit the corpse of a former president.
Yeah, the Ted Prize. We were like, what?
But that's how legit, legit man,
we went full, full throttle.
Don't worry. Don't worry. That doesn't
mean that the show is going to change.
Oh No, no, no. 100% jeans all the time.
100% genes. And in fact, I mean,
I don't want to give away any
surprises in the new studio yet,
but let's just say there's a lot of
things are finally going to happen.
I only going to happen and don't
think demanding. Oh, you guys are all
uppity now you got a new
studio. What does, what happens?
Does that mean that you're
going to have, um, you know,
guests to talk about math
now? No, it's the same. No.
Same world you love to live in with us.
It's going to be this thing z.
Oh my God.
Oh,
stuff like that. You
know? Sorry, I just was,
remember I was thinking about jeans and
my cat and I just wanted to share it.
Listen, we've had about six studios
now and that's no exaggeration.
So this the new ones, number six,
this is lucky. Six lucky six.
You want to take it through the the
I'd love to, yeah, let's do it. Go for it.
The first studio was in silver lake over
like in our apartment. That's right.
As a two bedroom.
One of the bedrooms became the room.
We did the show in and we shared a wall
with the person who lived behind us and
she would cook off of all things
Ethiopian food and it would,
we shared event and it would waft in
through the studio indoor room as we were
recording.
Cool thing about the setup
of that apartment was that
wall was like a false wall
paper sent. It was a person, it wasn't how
the, they made it two apartments, right?
There was one a correct.
So guess what?
If you wanted air conditioning a run,
she had to turn it on and her side,
then the AC would run, look, click on.
And it was also neat because we
knew her sexual behaviors came hard.
She came really hard. She did.
We knew it was freshly divorced.
She is fresh to divorce.
So there was a lot of do like our,
our bedroom walls border too.
So she could probably hear us
fucking and we could hear her. Yeah.
So she was kind of a performer.
It's strong performer.
She was a strong performance cleo shapes.
You would really celebrate,
you know, jeans and my cousin. Yeah.
Her jeans and Huracan and a guy.
Ah,
oh man.
Oh Man.
Oh Man. Ah, uh, so I remember, yeah,
that was the very first time we did
the show and if I can't even remember.
And then we did our,
and that's when we actually did start
using stamps.com because we were starting
to send out merge and it was so horrible.
Yeah.
And then the second studio we, we
would do, you guys don't understand.
So we would do, you know, a
shirt and set up. We literally,
you and I wouldn't have the
shirts in our house, right.
Shelves and honor the screen that said,
you know,
it was a paypal like set up
and the orange. Oh, okay.
We're still as a shirt.
And then sometimes you know,
the next morning you come
back and be like, wow,
we sold like 80 shirts and then we
would package and print the label.
That's right. For 80 shirts. You and I
would sit down and to keep in mind too,
Tommy and I had just started, we
were feature acts. So you know,
you fly out Wednesday night,
we performed Thursday, Saturday,
Sunday, Friday. Oh wait, sorry,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday
shows. And then we'd fly home Monday.
So we had about 72 hours before he
and I would have to go out again.
You do the road. And in those 72 hours
we had to make marital loves, you know,
have our dinners, catch up with each
other, pet the dog report, record,
the podcast quarter show. And that
took up the majority of a day. And,
and then we did merge, merge
on houses. I, by the way,
it's funny because in La people
would be like, do you live in la?
Like comics would see me somewhere in
there. I'd be like, do you live here?
And like, yeah, of course I live here.
And they're like, I never see you.
And I was always like, well, what
do you do? Like how do you do it?
Because I'm taking every week that I
get offered, both of us were of course,
fully packed or calendars or any offer
was yes, of course. Know that it would be,
the offers would be like hustle.
How Bout um, six shows? $600? Yes.
No airfare, no hotel, no hotel.
And the flight is $400 and you'd be
like, okay. Yeah, like that kind of shit.
You go into debt and that's why a lot
of people now it bothers me if they're
like, oh, you think you booze, you now
you fly in first class was like, yes,
of course I'm flying your first lesson
because I flew in the fucking back of the
bus and I put myself into debt. Becoming
a standup comic for a decade. Yes,
I'm flying first class asshole.
I earned it. You know you,
a lot of people don't who sometimes
people like let's say discover who you are
now.
They don't see the struggle.
They don't see that this
is year 16 up stand up.
16 years is a long time for me.
I'm talking about talking about practice,
talking about practice right now,
man.
I remember when we lived in
Silver Lake at doing that house.
I remember taking those 6:00 AM flights
across the country and I would wake up
at three 30 in the morning for
a member of those four hammers.
You wake up hoping that the taxi you
ordered or whatever was coming to get you
and your stomach would
hurt. Like you just, Oh God,
it's four in the fucking morning.
You drag your ass to a plane,
fall asleep during the announcements.
Wake up,
you know connect cause you're too
cheap to do the nonstop fucking brutal.
Do that twice a week.
Different Times zones,
eating fucking Kraft macaroni and cheese
out of microwave and you know the level
of Aki Anik that you live with.
When you're, oh my God opener,
trying to get that work.
It's so crazy. You live,
I mean eventually it actually sign up,
kind of goes down because becomes
your normal know. But it's um,
you live with this whole feeling of like,
all right,
what do I have this month and next month?
And then you go like this all week dude.
But I mean like once you get like a couple
months set up, you're like, all right.
But then when you get into
that second month and you ha,
you see that the next month is a down
month, you start to go like, oh shit.
Because you,
you know,
it's only if you have to remember that
every booking is just that weekend.
That's it.
You know,
like the big victories are then when you
start to go like booked out for a few
months because they booked, they usually
book a quarter at a time. So you'll,
you'll get your first quarter bookings,
what,
like the end of third quarter or
something. So yeah, you really,
you don't even know what your
year's going to look like.
Especially as an opener though.
It's an open or you have no say no say
and sometimes they'll call you and be
like, oh, what are you
doing? We have a fall out.
Can you fly to Miami tomorrow to
start shows? And you're like that,
that plane tickets like $800 I guess so.
Cause I want to work that club and I want
to fuck it up. If it was a filet, yeah,
fall out. But I still remember getting um,
Hartford for some reason. I don't know.
You did fight for it a lot in the early,
I remember opening and Hartford
and they were like, you know,
here's the offer when you middle,
it's $100 a show la to Hartford.
It was like five 50,
uh, fortunate. And I'm like,
that means I'll make $50.
And they were like, do you
want to do it as a course?
Okay. And then you just, yeah.
You just, you're like, I'll wrack
up the debt on this. And we did.
And that's thing people, yeah, we, you
and I went into debt to become headliners.
And then once your headline here,
you're still not really your,
this is how I'm making money.
I'll tell you this about making money.
We do this as a comedian.
So at the,
I'm trying to think the,
the year that I shot
my comedy Central, Oh, I'll tell you this,
2008 around 2008 late 2008 we get married
at the end of 2008 I get a phone call
that I got my first round
of offers from the Improv's,
meaning like multiple
weeks of headlining work,
which is huge,
which is a bump because now you're,
you're actually in the system and
your name is on the thing you want to
basically,
and it is quite an elite club.
When you get the call of like the Improv's
gave me offers and the funny bones.
What that means is you're one of,
there's only 52 weeks.
So out of all the lunatics in the
world, all the scumbags, the Lex,
the Weirdos who want to be standup comics,
you're one a 52 lucky people.
It's very,
it's very lucky that gets
his fucking actually do this
for a living proficiently.
It's crazy.
I remember this. Okay.
I remember this detail.
I worked the first 11 weeks in a row,
so that's all of January,
February and basically almost
all of March. Took a week off.
Then worked the next nine
weeks in a row and I was like,
and my head as I was working I was like,
oh like I'll get to chill later and at
the end of those nine weeks I had to go
get a part time job.
Right.
Because it wasn't enough money to live
of course as an like as a first year
headliner and then the next year 2010
I still had a part time job and shot a
comedy central half hour special bananas
and I still had to get a part time
person and then 2011 I
worked at a like a little,
I started to it less the part time and
I think I didn't have a part time like I
was like a site rep on those
shoots like showing up.
It's making like hourly stuff.
I don't think that actually stopped
completely until end of 2011 beginning of
2012 it's not that long.
Yeah.
Not that long ago either because when I,
yeah, I was headlining. I was doing weeks.
My last day job I was on.
Okay,
so the borrow 2011 I think 2012 I
was doing Chelsea lately. The panel,
right? The round table.
Yeah. I would literally go do
Chelsea lately. I would know.
Here's what I would do first.
Oh,
you got the booking I you're going
to do Chelsea tomorrow. Great.
I would go down to the mall, the
Grove. I would check out clothing.
I would go to nice stores, buy the
outfit I was going to wear on the show,
on a credit card,
leave the tags where it on the show,
where it on the show and the round table.
So I had something nice
to wear the next day,
take the clothes immediately back
and then I would go to my day job.
I worked at the girl scouts
of Greater Los Angeles.
I worked in the front desk
and I would, people would be
like, Oh, you want Chelsea?
Lately last night and I'm like, Yep,
and I'm working here at the girl scouts.
Did you do that too?
I want to say 2012 I believe was
my last year of having a day job.
And then I became,
and then I just kept getting book as a
headline and doing what you were doing.
Like back to back to back to back.
You just had to,
you have to keep working as a headliner.
And then we did our podcast and then
TV stuff kept coming and the stuff kept
throwing, telling people you
gotta stay, you gotta stay in.
It just got to keep all it is.
It's a marathon and it's,
it's a game of attrition
like David Goggins. Right.
You got fucking beat your mind,
man. You gotta you just got it.
Who's the toughest motherfucker
out there? That's all it is, dude.
Who was the toughest and also failure.
Like I've,
I had 22 jobs in four years
before I became a standup comic.
I had exhausted all the possibilities.
I dropped out of law school,
I dropped out of graduate school,
like I fucking did it. All. This is
on both sides. That that's
totally, I agree. Yeah.
So let's go back to our list.
So there is silver lake,
that was the first studio and then we
moved to Redondo and we had a two bedroom
in Redondo. We lived in a tiny
guest house. That's right.
And we turned the basically
second bedroom into our studio,
into our studio there. And that was fine.
Those were good years. Then we got Fifo,
we did get Fifo,
then a little jeans,
ls jeans was born.
So as when we knew he was coming,
we knew that that room had to be the
nursery. Right. So we got an office,
this is amazing.
We've got an office like three
blocks away and this office complex.
And I remember signing the office lease
and the guy wanted three years and I was
like, how about two years?
And then he was like, no,
we don't do anything less than
three. So I was like, all right.
And like six months later we moved.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Well,
we didn't realize that having a baby and
two dogs cause we also had gotten bitsy
just as I found out I was pregnant with
Ellis and I wasn't about to give a puppy
back that we, you know, I
committed to getting this dog.
So I raised a puppy while pregnant and
then we had Ellis and then it was you,
me Ellis and two dogs and a tiny guest
house and Redondo and we were losing our
minds and we were also still doing tons
of road work. And while you were yeah,
I was home taking care of
the baby. Especially where
a grinding those weeks bro.
Cause when you get to your first baby,
believe me, you're like a book. Me,
you get terrified when it was funny
at the time too. Is that your career?
I just started really taking off when
Ellis was born and we had been broke for
so long and I remember you telling me
cause I was like what are we going to do
this baby? And you're like
no babe, we've got money now.
And I was like no we don't. And you
go, no, it's swear to God. Look, look,
we have like a little bit of money
now. And I was like, you're kidding me.
This happened.
Like when did this happen?
I was so preoccupied with being pregnant
and my mom had died. Like I didn't,
I looked up and our life had
pretty much completely changed.
And then you know, things, things
got way different once, you know,
your first special on Netflix, completely
normal was there. And that took off.
And then the second special and then your
mom's house grew and grew and then it
was our lives completely.
Once Ellis
was born, it totally did. Yeah. And we
went to, by the way, the crazy thing was,
uh, you know, when we left Redondo,
I had to get a job every day.
Yeah. We're done. That was great. I love
the, I love that beach community. Ah,
but we left there.
The guy that got us the office was able
to find somebody to sublease the office,
which was a huge relief,
you know? Yeah. So he did.
And then like, I think we told it
on here, but like, uh, you know,
six months ago this guy was like, you
need to clean your off again, email,
you need to clean your office and he's
like, need to clean your office. And I go,
why is it cause it stinks.
And I go, look man, I go,
I haven't been down there in a
couple of years now because of the,
the lease ended like seven,
eight months ago.
So I guess it's like before like around
then, right, like a, it was about eight,
nine months ago from
now. I'm saying. Yeah.
So cause that was the end of like the
three year lease. So he's like, you know,
there's only a month left but it's
filthy. And I go, how's it? I go,
why are you telling me yet? I
sublease it and he's like, oh yeah,
well what's that guy's number? I go,
I don't even know man. Like yeah,
this was all set up through
the real estate guy.
I haven't been down there in a
few years. And he's like, well,
I'm just letting you know that I'm going
in there because it stinks. And I go,
I write back to him, I go, you're
telling the wrong guy? Yeah.
Like somebody took over the
lease and he's like, all right.
And then the next day he's like,
oh yeah.
It turns out the guy that sublease it
from you died in there and that's the
smell.
Did you hear my husband just said the man,
he subleased it died in our old studio.
Yeah.
Left.
Like where we used to film the show and
he was in there so long decamping that
right. That uh, the, the building,
you know, the room started to smell.
Then they said they got the body
out of there and he was like, oh,
um, you're going to need it,
clean it up. And I was like,
what are you talking about? That's a
wipey not an emptiness problem, man. No.
So we went through like this
insurance thing. I was like,
no, it's not. No, no, no.
But they had to actually,
it's a small office building.
They actually evacuated the entire
building for a couple of days.
Is that because of the smell was
so strong and that was our third.
Your Mom's house studio. Right.
Just so you know right now.
Can I tell you why that makes me really
happy though that a guy died? Yes.
Why does next door to us I go next
door to us was of again thin walls.
I don't know why you and I always seem
to pick places within walls and the
fucking bitch next door would you every
phone call on speaker phone and then she
had a thing of like Christmas
bells on her door year round.
So whenever anybody open and shut the door
dangling and link slam dangling links,
lamb. And she was yelling into her
speaker phone all long and I was like,
please
just,
she probably filed the first complaint.
That's where I'm hoping those two
need to clean up their stinky student.
Here's why I'm happy is knowing that the
smell wafted into her life and ruin her
life just a little bit as she ruined
that for people that don't know,
Redondo is like 30 plus miles from central
La and we used to ask people to come
to our show like like you know,
tax or something and like other
comics they'd be like, yeah man,
give me the address and I'd send it and
then like you'd just wait a beat and
they'd be like,
hey man,
I didn't realize where you are a no
because nobody was cause it was really it.
That was a commute. That's why we
ended up moving back to the city. Yeah.
Once we had Ellis we couldn't,
I didn't want to spend an hour and a half
in traffic away from my kid just to go
into the city and back. It was
craziness. It was terrible.
So that studio number three,
somebody died in studio number four was
that of a house we rented as we were
looking for this house.
So then that was another bedroom
that we converted into our,
we fucked that walls,
those fuck that up.
Put up some foam adhesive spray,
actually move.
We tore it off and it just like patches
and the guy that owned it
and then she was like, um,
these walls are pretty fucked up.
We'll be talking about are yeah,
they're pretty good
like this before I know.
I remember him looking like that and
that was a fun to do. And that one Ellis,
his bedroom bordered that studio.
So some days the baby would be sleeping
and Tom and I would record the show and
about the 45 minutes that we had when
Ellis was sleeping and those are those
days I was fun. And then we found this
place which is a house with a studio,
which is really cool.
Right.
And now we're going to fuck that all up
by building a studio at another location.
So we, we don't have to utilize
the convenience of the home studio.
Exactly what I like.
I like making things in convenience.
I like not having people at our house.
That's true.
Your private privacy private.
Yeah.
I don't like everyone coming over
here and I also feel like, look,
it's a proper upgrade this show.
Thanks to the people that listen and
watch this that have grown and grown and
grown to my thing.
I always was like,
I want to deliver a product that I feel
like honestly like they deserve and I
think the show deserves, which is this
new space because it looks amazing.
The sound's going to be amazing. It
really is. Total and complete upgrade.
If you want to talk about our inspiration
for the design on the studio. Yeah,
so a few years back we were having dinner
in Austin and we were at this dark ass
steakhouse and Tom and I both
were like, God, this is so great.
I think I wish everything
looked like this.
Like I wish my house looked
like steakhouses let go.
We'd love steak houses.
Every time we tell people what our
aesthetic is, or like it's steak house,
it's dark brown. I've talked
designers for all types of things,
homes and other other pro projects I've
worked on. They're like, well wait,
what are you like?
I'm like a of like steak houses.
This one not as dark as a steakhouse,
but it has a nice aesthetic to it. Well,
I'll tell you what we
told the guy we said,
steak house meets masterpiece theater.
Yeah. So you'll see that soon.
I'm very excited to show that to
you. Um, it's going to be fantastic.
And I like you said too, I'm excited
to, to upgrade the quality of the show.
We're going to have people, you
know, producing things more and yeah,
just more production value.
Same Old genes inside of studio genes,
same genes, different Turlock, different
tonic, different color. You know,
I just realized, oh wait, wait, wait.
May, may I just finish one thought though.
I wanted to say I knew,
I knew when the show took a turn.
Here's when I first knew that your
mom's house had become something really
special.
And this is why I brought this whole
thing up when you played jeans in my cunt.
I remember, remember when we did your
mom's house live in Toronto? Matt Miller.
Is that his name? I tried to, the
guy that, I'm not sure. Toronto,
I'm not sure. Memory. We did Toronto.
That was wild. What year was that?
We did Toronto.
Um,
maybe 2014.
Yeah,
I would be pregnant with Ellis that
year. No you wouldn't. I was pregnant.
20 delivered him in December of 20 1525
was I was pregnant all of 2015 yeah,
you're right. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
And I remember when we went to
Toronto and we did this theater. Yeah.
For your mom's house and for stand up and,
and we sold out every ticket so
fast was great. And I, and I,
I went out and I wear
denim on Joe to Trudeau,
to Joe to Tia who owns
like a comedy club now.
I believe they call it the corner
corner comedy club. I think any huddles.
Sorry Joe.
We don't go there cause it's too fucking
far to get there from the west coast.
But anyways, I'm going back
to Toronto. He's trying to,
it's just such a hassle to go fucking
customs. They're such jerks. Yeah.
Anyways,
I remember coming out on stage wearing
the Canadian Tuxedo and you, my,
my introduction, you wrote, you go proud
winds are native Christina rather. Yeah.
And I remember looking out and like
they were, that people were going nuts.
So then we were playing jeans in my
con while people were being seated.
We put that playlist. I remembered
people jamming it to it and I was like,
this is crazy. This is finally
not finally, but this is,
I can't believe people really like
this nonsense that we're doing.
And that's when I realized
that we had some and we,
after we met all the people
that had come to the shelf,
they put a million genes up on, they
really did that. They hung genes.
So cute outside of the awning,
like all the way around
the front of the building,
if you're driving by,
you would just see jeans and outside
and people waiting in line would walk by
like a hundred pairs of jeans.
So silly. I love that. I love to,
to that whole crew is so
sweet. Test. It's still is.
But that's the first time I knew that
your mom's house had grown and it was the
beginning of something big, something
very big. And even now, I mean I,
I'm afraid to tour with your
mom's house. Who knows? Shit,
we have to do fucking arenas.
I just want to, I dunno.
It'd be fun to go do some live ones.
We'll see. Well, if the kids are so young,
maybe when the kids are a bit older,
we can take them on the road.
I want to take a fucking infant.
No small.
We could probably do a one or
two night or somewhere. Yeah,
but I have to pee so bad right now.
I drank so much water and I had that.
It's the green shake. I'm sorry. I, I
got p. What do you want me to do it?
They just press pause for one second.
All right. All right. All right.
I just drained my, cut my fucking
cut. Well, I just realized that, uh,
we haven't done a proper show in
almost 30 minutes and we haven't done
our dates either. My fucking cat,
my cat, my cat and my
cat. Well, it's sexy.
Is that, is that Jules? No, no, no. No.
Fucking Cup with another strong performer.
Who says my fucking cunt.
Oh,
women don't call their vaginas.
Confluence. Do you ready? Ready.
Let's start it.
This is Matt.
He harmed a BDO.
Never been on get harmed him for my laugh.
I swear I'm not wanting to go out,
run around looking for dates. Just
all time. I'm looking for a woman.
I'm not real picky.
And I know people say,
why are you settling for something
when you could get a lot better? Sure.
No
ice settle.
Can I tell you something?
I'll tell you what the world is changing.
It's the end of the white male
oppression era, right? And listen,
white men have done a lot of great things.
You guys have created civilizations
and contained, contained fire,
quantum mechanics, all
that shit. Not to mention,
not to mention,
but I got to tell you,
the level of delusion of these white men
about what they think they deserve in
the world is real.
And that is a direct result
of check your privilege.
I don't believe in that shit.
Entitlements for the viewers.
Teitelman for the listeners who are
not watching what you're seeing,
he looks a little bit like Ron Howard.
Does Ron Howard have hair anymore?
Ron Howard's brother. Yeah, that guy.
That guy's fucking amazing.
Yeah.
Jesus never been on it. Your him.
I'm not wanting to go out, run around
looking for dates. It's dial time.
I'm looking for a woman.
I'm not real picky.
Ah, okay. No. People say why are you
settling when you'd get a lot bad.
Okay, that's amazing. Can floor it.
Preferably a blond haired woman
that my side somewhere around.
Oh class cause your towel.
1520 pounds. A 1520
right? Sure. Cook claim.
Oh I and grab me and all my appointments.
Oh what appointments are those?
Not The dentist for we send might
go to the pain clinic but what
keeps me from having to go work?
What?
The what?
Preferably somebody who goes to pain
clinics. See this is why you need teeth.
I don't,
people are like why do I need teeth
will because nobody can understand what
you're saying.
Referred. We shouldn't paint
pain. Thank. Thank you.
Keep me ma'am.
Go cause like I'll paint green rock.
Unreal. This guy fucking
making me so mad. So angry.
So mad and he's such a piece of shit.
This guy is such a fucking useless piece
of shit and there's women out there.
There's so much better than this
guy. He goes to paint a lot. Yeah.
Wow.
Lack to have Bergen
Bergen 2030 year old.
Okay.
One or to my real shit.
[inaudible]
yeah. Do you like teeth? I can't. I
can't even watch them without the teeth.
This has to be a bit right.
Performance space though. No.
Hitting all the numbers and he's
like, no, he's doing this face.
This is real bad because his real
face. Yeah. Golden like that.
Yeah.
This guy has a drunk man.
I love this new segment of delusional
men that were doing big asks as what
wrong? It was like big asks. Yeah. Yeah.
This is a delusional male category.
Yeah. This is what I deserve.
It's so hard
how black long walk, because I mostly
stay around the house, home body,
but I do like thick.
Oh, what do you imagine
that guy? Okay, let's do it.
What's the dollar amount?
Hold on, hold on, please.
Brack. Finally, Young Bergen is,
we don't have a lot of faith
that find me a whole lot.
I've got to add down
[inaudible] right now.
I had that much luck yet cause that when
Ratan back upbringing and I won't know
ugly woman,
so he hasn't had it been having a lot
of luck with some of his other ads,
the place other places.
Because some of those women that have
written back or ugly and he doesn't want
an ugly woman. No, no
dessert here.
If you're live where white
[inaudible] I don't give a crap.
Wow. [inaudible] party.
And regarding that,
you may get in contact
when we'll get together.
Okay. Ah, that's, that's gotta be a bit,
it's got to be a bit, here's ended it
by going on. He knows what he's doing.
He's got to be, it's all
exaggeration. Well, here's the
deal. Made me laugh though.
Here's the deal, man. It's got
the qualifications of a great,
your mom's house does have
it. I just don't know if, if,
if he, if he's self aware.
It's funny that he's doing well. Let's
go through the checklist, shall we? Okay.
A crappy lighting check.
Poor angle check.
Uh, background noise. Not
really. Okay. So he, he,
he knew to make it quiet for
his video. Okay. Location.
He looks like he's in a closet.
He's in the closet.
It's um, no cheese, which is a big win.
That's a new, yeah, that's definitely
why I'm a big qualifier. Yeah.
Uh, when you get the notes, he gotta have
no teeth to make a good video. Yeah. You,
you know, if you want it to be a
strong winning video, how about this,
how much money for him to give you
a blow job with those nice new TV.
Jesus Christ.
Babe.
He's got no team and that
kind of every guy's dream.
Yeah.
How much for him to blow you?
Let's talk in the number that's a,
uh, man. Hmm.
Be Realistic too. I want, I want tax free
cash,
tax free cash off the books.
How much for that guy to blow you?
I'm trying to think.
MMM.
There'll be a lot. It would
have to be a lot. I mean,
I think it'd be really
horrifying to have that guy,
you know,
blow me. So I can't really, it's kind of,
I'm just trying to think about,
okay, how much does the French in
man, that alone, and I'm
not even exaggerating,
I'm being very sincere here.
Yeah. Think about it. Yeah.
Like if you put the money in
a briefcase and you're like,
Uncle Sam doesn't touch
it. Yeah. Not Traceable.
I would have to do a million and
$1 million to kiss him to French.
Kiss him,
his tongue and your tongue.
You were talking about scissoring that
crazy lady for like a hundred grand,
but that's not your mouth.
Your mouth on someone else's mouth is
like the most intimate thing you can do.
Now we know you're just full of nonsense.
What are you talking about?
Your mouth is your most private,
private, exclusive area.
I think I put my mouth on that
fucking nasty mouth. No teeth. Okay,
well who would,
why doesn't he have the perfect smile?
Can we send this guy the perfect smile?
Who would you thought need to
needs is the perfect smile?
Who would you make love to first?
That Guy
[inaudible] don't like
him at all. He's creepy.
I'm going to throw out
little boys. Okie doke.
Thanks. I got it. Oops. I
don't care about their partner,
right? He's a loving partner. He's a
thoughtful guy. I don't like him the most.
I don't like him the most. I would take
the other guy over. This guy. Really?
This guy is so nasty to me.
He's like a serial killer. Okay.
What about between this guy?
This guy right here. Okay. The,
I'll make you cum guy.
So I'll make you come
versus the last guy versus,
hold on, let me set it up for you.
I'll take the four stroke versus
when you said to me you want to
go back with your boyfriend, okay,
please erase him from your
memory. Okay. Here's the thing.
All three present different problems.
So let's go through those problems.
Take me through your logic. Okay. Uh,
dom make you calm.
Guy Actually at his core
is an insecure little boy,
right? But he's going to talk a
big talk. A lot of sexual bravado.
He's going to be a little
difficult to deal with. He's gonna,
he's gonna do that nagging thing you're
talking about where you put the girl
down, maybe to me feel, well,
I've seen prettier. Right. Anyway,
you'll be like,
but he's older,
so it's going to be actually harder to
make him calm unless he's taking Viagra.
Right? The second guy out, the
toothless wonder, that guy is drunk.
He's going to fall asleep.
He's going to pass out drunk.
He's not even going to be awake
for that. So it'll be easy. Yeah.
He'll diarrhea his pants or something. And
then, okay, so I think between the two,
you're going with the drunk.
No. Then there's Joe, right?
I'm saying I'm talking about the first two
though. You'd be like, yeah, the, yeah,
the, the second toothless guy over
Joe would be attentive. I think.
Here's the problem. Here's the problem
with Joe. I think we all know you're done.
And then he's like, this is just
duct tape and it's not going to hurt,
but this way when I give back, you know,
we can talk some more and you're like,
mmm, alright. Right. Yeah.
Joe's like obsessive and scary
and you're living in his basement,
right? Like he's going to hold me
hostage and have sex with my tied up body
relentlessly all day. So where does
that, but what order does that put it?
This is so disgusting. Yeah, that's
a good one. Okay. Third places.
Joe For obvious mortal mortal
danger. Oh Wow. Mortal danger.
I hope this video doesn't scare you.
Second place I'll make you calm guy.
Disgusting.
And then first started brand new toothless
drunk. He's just a toothless drunk.
Wow. He's not obsessive. He's
a little delusional. Exciting.
What about you?
He doesn't mind
and over.
Are you disappointed?
Oh, I got it. Yeah. Do you want him?
But don't forget.
The Nice thing is I'm not real picky.
He's not real picky. Lisa. You
could be flat like 130 away.
One 30 blonde,
pretty virgin.
So you would really let them
down and that department, oh,
all these clocks around the block.
I'm morbidly obese by his
standards and I'm real SLE.
Ut Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
How do you get that far where you
don't care if you even have teeth?
Like can you order the perfect spouse? He
doesn't care. It's $10 he doesn't care.
I don't give a crap.
So it sounds like you're ordered to recap
is you take him first because it seems
like second place is I'll make you come.
Yeah.
And third places.
Joe God,
Joe Definitely is the most coherent and
has things the most together and he said
third but that's the
problem is that he'll,
he will actually go
through with intercourse.
The other two are just big talkers and
you could probably get away with like
giving them a hand job.
Joe is going to be like,
I want to love you on one of romance.
You talk about this baby we're
going to have. And you're like,
we just started dating.
He's want to make eye contact with you
as I'm making love to you and have a
family. He's got it. You'll be actually
the most fascinating thing we had,
Julia and Julia introduced us to
him and everything and you know,
she obviously saw the
red flags and running.
Wouldn't it be fascinating to
talk to one of Joe's x's love to.
That would be, that'd be better
than having Joe on love to, Oh,
I don't want to talk to Joe. No,
no. We already know his story.
I would love to be like a me to go. She
was like, I dated Joe for six months.
Six months. Anybody makes it that long.
Oh yeah, for sure. And he's got a kid,
so he's got those ones. So if someone's
had a relationship with them, probably.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It would be.
Yeah.
Kind of crazy.
Yeah. You go ahead. Just, she's
so precious. Precious to me.
Oh, look what you did to me. Yeah.
That's why that last one you did to me.
Fucking bitch.
I'll fuck is strangle you.
You stupid bitch.
Call me on the couch with
me and I'll fucking kill you
again.
And he's padding his stomach.
I'm half asleep on the couch.
You're disappointed you got me
wrapped around your finger. Cute.
But that's all you get.
I'm exhausted.
He goes, this is Ali. Yeah.
Disappointed. He's saying,
he's saying that she's disappointed
that he's not gonna do a bigger
man. That would have been so
fun. Julian. Her friends be like,
send us another cool video.
I would love to see their
bait video like Jo Marie,
would you please send me a video?
Only though not a text and I want to be
able to watch it over and over and over
and celebrate.
Look what she's done to me.
I'm half asleep on the couch.
Yeah.
So gross.
Have you ever done that?
Like a sexy video? No. Right?
You never did it for me.
Fuck No. That's not me man. Like
I'm just laying here on this,
on this couch right now.
Girl. I'd probably send some
pictures I'm embarrassed of,
but not to me. No, I'm talking
about other road beef chicks.
Oh, what about your dream and your
ma? Your newer drinking? Yeah.
So your Black Hawk fantasy that people
remember from a few weeks ago where we
saw the Lakers and then you're like,
I had a dream.
You had a Black Hawk
last night by the way.
What do they do with their cocks during
the games? And we were like, okay,
no work is seen as the lines
that, you know, it's, it's
funny because I don't like,
I don't, I don't, I've never dated a
black guy. I don't have a preference.
I know,
I know
odd that,
that we went to the Laker game and I came
home and I dreamt that you and I were
making sweet marital loves
and that everything about
you was in regular colored
for you regular colored and then white
guy. Right? Like you are Tom Colored.
You were normal in the,
I meant you were a regular for you,
like the regular clothes that you always
are and then you're dong was chocolate.
Yeah. You had a chocolate black
Ding Dong. And I was like,
and I remember in the dream tripping out
like Whoa, Tom's kind of a black one.
A big black one. Yeah. And then I was
like, all right, I guess it's my husband.
It's okay.
Cause here's a weird thing about my dreams
and you even in my like I love you so
much and I mean this,
I don't even cheat on you in my dreams.
I can't even have a sexual
dream about somebody else,
which kind of fucking sucks actually in
a way. Like I can't even in my dreams,
I'm like, no, I'm a good wife.
I actually obviously listen,
do I ever tell you where I'm like, dude,
I dreamt that I slept with somebody else.
Yeah.
Never get to girl with no
arms and one leg. Yeah,
no arms and one leg. Yeah. Geez. Yeah.
So then last night I had another dream
and this time I dreamt that I had a new
husband and it was the guy from entourage.
It was like, I think the guy that,
it's like a blonde guy, I think it
plays, plays his agent or something.
Any huddles. And this was so this time
you weren't with me though. So the dream,
I was in our house and then this
blonde guy came and he take,
he took me away from you and the next
thing I know, he goes, all right sweetie,
I'm going to work. And he gives
me kissing. And I'm like, oh,
are you my husband now?
And he and I,
and I got really sad and scared and I
was looking for you and looking for Tanya
Lee in your dream. Yeah. I was like,
where's my husband? Where's my husband?
And then I saw you finally coming in
in a black coat and I saw your head and
your beard. And I was like,
oh, it's Tommee, it's Tommee.
And then I got all excited
and that you were back.
And then this morning I
woke up and I snuggled.
You definitely have different
dreams. No. Who are you begging?
Definitely never see you on that side.
I just,
I just see that road. Beav
and there's, you know,
there's very,
very little.
Okay. Let's talk about your
aversion to snap watering. Good.
Go ahead. Let's talk about your
aversion to snuggling. Um, yeah, I,
uh, I'm an virgin to
snuggling. I like styling.
I don't snuggle to sleep.
That's the difference all I want.
Why do you think I have
two dogs? Well, I'm,
I'm just telling you I can't
snuggle to sleep. I could snuggle.
And then it's like, now I got to go
to sleep. I don't snuggle with sleep.
I don't know. I just can't. It's
uncomfortable to sleep that way. I enjoy,
I like the affection of
snuggling to express love,
but then if it's like I got to go to
sleep, I don't sleep that way. I can't,
I don't know what you're
going to tell you. Well,
you got me wrapped around your finger.
No precious. The thing
is too, you love you.
You also don't like being hot.
That's always your big fucking
lie to me like that. It's too hot.
I'm fat. And in fact, people don't like
to be hot because they're naturally hot.
Okay? You're just figuring
this out. Fat. I'm fat.
You're not fat. Fat. I'm gross, Mary Rose.
But uh, I don't, I don't, I've never
liked a warm room or anything like that.
I don't like,
obviously.
I know my whole life is a struggle with
you and you're like, I have a fever.
That's feels terrible the way you're, I
like it. Cool. By the way, I never win.
It's always fucking hot in there. It's
not hot. You'll have it. 77 I'll work.
Perfect. Okay. When I was
on the road, by the way,
I angered a lot of people
on the inner webs. Yeah.
With my Instagram posts and my thermostat
in Philly and in Jude or titties.
It was so fucking cold.
Yeah.
I had it up to 77 and truth be
told and Judah are titties. Yeah.
I would have cranked it up to 80. Oh, my
conscience didn't let me really, well,
my bed was right by the window
and the draft was coming in.
I was very cold and I was
wearing flannel pajamas.
Mm. Well look, here's the thing
we're going to do right now.
I'm super excited. I'm so excited.
Hold on. I want to make sure I can.
Um,
is this a why IMH exclusive?
It is kind of a why a major
collusive but I want to
get this thing ready for you guys so that
you know what we're talking about here.
Oh, um, God, what? Which binder is it in?
I have so many, this is one of the
reasons I liked the idea of going to a new
studio so that I don't have to
search for something every time.
I want to show it to you guys will
have painful to listen to dad.
It's painful to do it though. Well
you're not helping, that's for sure.
You're definitely not helping.
You're not helping at all.
What are you talking about? You never
helped but this stuff I just do it.
Or Can I help though?
You're the only one you control one thing.
Maybe by not saying like
it's real fun to listen to.
So like stress the person out more like
as they're doing it. You mean like that?
This is the last time you're
ever going to do this.
That's why I'm giving you
shit the last time. All right,
well we're having the video FX supervisor
from tiptoes tiptoes is going to join
me on a call right now.
Um, it is very exciting.
I will say that I don't think if I'm,
if I'm correct that you're going to be
on the call and I have a phone call and
make myself, I'm sorry. Okay. So our
schedules and Nona line on this one.
Okay.
So the video effects supervisor,
so wild from tip toes,
tip top tip toes. They're
the title. It's just,
that's embarrassing. Woo Hoo.
Greenlit the title. Tip Toes.
Um, I have no idea. Toes.
This guy is coming on,
so we're going to ask him questions.
I gotta ask him questions about this.
You'll be back for the second part of the
[inaudible] test. Okay. All right guys.
Here it is. Um, gene, go make your call,
cal. Love you. Bye. Bye. All right,
here we go.
It is time for a y m h exclusive.
This is a wagon again.
H exclusive.
All right,
here we go.
Hello, Doug? Yes.
Hey, it's Tom Segura. How are you?
Good. How are you? I'm doing well man.
Thanks so much for, uh, taking the call
of course.
So we have become semi obsessed,
uh,
since discovering honestly just
the long form trailer for tiptoes,
um, like over and over.
Can't stop watching it.
Okay.
You were the video effects supervisor,
is that correct?
Okay.
Oh,
visual effects producer yet,
sorry.
Visual effects producer on the film.
The thing. Okay. One of the
things before we get into,
like for some reason,
you know,
I never was aware of the
movie when it came out.
Somebody sent in this trailer and
when we watched the trailer were like,
this isn't real. Um,
because the trailer, yeah,
I dunno if you've watched
it recently or anything,
but it has like this parody quality to it,
like where it's cut to feel like
it's not real. Does that make sense?
It does.
You know,
I actually work now at a company
that produces a lot of trailers. Uh,
and so, uh, that whole voiceover style,
that whole method of
presenting the character,
it just doesn't happen anymore. And
that's why it feels so parody. Right.
It cuts the movie is so ridiculous.
I mean it's,
it's this incredible actors
somehow bound up in that movie.
Do you remember to figure out,
do you remember when you're working on
it? Like, cause I, I'm always kind of,
I was always fascinated by this.
I have a little bit of experience
now as an actor in film.
So some of my questions about it, I
was able to answer. Right. I did three,
I did three films this year,
one big studio movie and to independence.
And I remember, I used to always
wonder if during a filming,
like during a shoot,
like when you're actually shooting a film,
whether you get the feeling or not,
like this is going to be dog
shit or this is going to be good.
Like whether you can know and the truth
is ultimately you can have sensations
about it, but you'll, you'll never really
know it. At least in my experience.
You're kind of like, well, you know,
this seems to be going really well.
I have hope for it. Or maybe
you're working in, you're like, ah,
this is kind of kind of sloppy.
This isn't,
I don't know what's going to happen here.
Like it's,
it's still a toss up though until you
see it cut. I mean, where you actually,
since you're visual effects,
where you there like throughout the shoot,
were you there?
Like the run a picture?
I was on and off. It
wasn't there every day. Um,
but certainly it wasn't,
it was the sense of sort of,
this may not be good.
It was such chaos every day.
And every decision was so strange
because there was this battle between,
you know, these great actors, again,
some of their representatives that are
talented producers in their own right.
Okay.
And then the p,
well some balls were all pretty
talented indie producers,
but then there was this
constant undercurrent of
these really low budget, uh,
crew people, uh, not against the
crew, but sort of some of the,
the upper management of it that
were just only interested in,
in how expensive everything
might might or might not be.
And we're cutting left and
right as we went through it,
even my budget started out pretty decent,
certainly indie level,
visual effects budget. And one
day I just got a call like, Hey,
I'm stopping payment on those checks.
We're not going to do any of those visual
effects. So you were not paying it. And
I mean it was just such,
it was every day was like,
so this movie was, was in, it
was like an indie budget movie,
is that correct?
Okay.
Correct. Okay. So the guys,
the actor is the big name signed on
because they must have bought into the
script.
I mean that's always why you land the,
the out of this world
level talent and you know,
certainly having Gary Oldman and even
at the time Macada Hay and back in sale,
we're like, these are big above
the title kind of names. They,
they must, this script must have really
hit them as a great piece of writing
there. Sure. I don't recall reading
the script and feeling that way, but,
but certainly it's spoke to at least
one of them first and plugs, you know,
at the time, I have to assume it
was Gary and I think, I think,
I know it was Gary initially who
was intrigued by the idea of it.
Right. Number one, the script had
some quality too. He was, you know,
he's an adventurer. He's an amazing
talent. And, and he was like,
well I can do this. Right. Maybe.
And then I think he was somewhat in
between projects. Let's say you held,
he'd had a lot of great projects
beforehand, but this was, you know,
early two thousands before he had
gotten the Harry Potter Gig. Yeah.
40 has gotten the Batman stuff
and so he needed a gig probably.
Yeah. And it all sort of
aligned for him to get involved.
And then once you start going
out with, hey, you know,
Gary opens going to do this,
then you can convince eight and
Matthew and Peter Dinklage and Patricia
Arquette. I mean it just keeps
going. Keeps going up. These people,
you can keep all these people,
you can convince all these people that
it's worth a shot now and they're good.
So do when you wait two days,
you know,
when you're actually, you know,
let's say midway through it,
there is like the chaos,
the budget stuff.
Do you of, do you, do you still
go like you have hope for it?
Like are you still hopeful
that this turns out well,
I guess,
I mean,
I knew one of the main producers
soon the dollars was uh,
John Langley and his company and he's
best known as the guy who does cops.
Right. Because that gives
you an indication of these
are people getting into the
business. They are aligning themselves
with the people who had been around.
But again,
you know,
you also have to consider that time
where a lot of these movies were getting
made just to fill the shelves.
Right.
You have blockbuster then
needed to constantly fill
the shelves with new movies.
Right?
Yeah.
This is all,
oh, sorry, I'm losing
you a little bit there.
Hmm.
Oh, hey. Hey [inaudible].
Oh yeah. Oh yeah, I'm much better.
So you, you said though that you,
you were like somewhat hopeful, but like,
not really sure. I'm guessing right. Of,
of how it would go.
I mean, I mean for sure. Uh, you know,
because it was so interesting and there
was so many crazy things going on.
And again, you have to have faith
in these actors. Uh, but it,
it did seem like I said, like, like
things were off the rails, no question,
uh, given, given just what was
going on every day on set. I mean,
you had a set filled with little
people who are all very professional,
but it was a lot of things to Wrangell.
And then you had all these actors,
uh, you know, kind of finding
their way through this thing. Um,
and so it was a, it was an
interesting experience. I mean, uh,
there was a day we were shooting this one,
one of the main VFX shots,
uh, Gary kind of walks down the hallway
and turns and knocks on the door.
And you realize also that I think his
girlfriend's played by Bridget the midget.
Right. Which is another,
you know, incredible thing.
How did she wind up there? But
she did. Um, so, so anyway, he's,
he's walking down and,
and,
and it's a set up as a specific setup
for visual effects. And He, um, you know,
they have these little shoes they had
made to go around his knees. And I said,
well, I need you to, you know, walk
with those on because we're not sort of,
all we're trying to do is just remove
the back of your legs were we weren't
supposed to animate a shoe.
And He,
and he and hit the prop guy
are like, no, no, no, no.
We were told we would never have to
walk with these shoes. I'm like, well,
I don't know what to tell you. I don't
think we can figure this out right now.
Is there any way you can do
it? And so they agree to do
it. He walks down, he does,
you know, we do the take and, and they
caught and I'm like, well, you know,
you're kind of leaning back because
obviously he's on his knees shuffling
long, shuffling with you're leaning
back with shoes around his knees,
I'm assuming.
Right.
These little, these little shoes.
Right. So, uh, he, I'm like,
you got to kind of stand up straight
and if you could, cause we, you know,
we're going to make a knee there. And,
and he just said, he just loses it.
And he says, uh, and again, I
have great respect for the man.
I hate to telling stories out of school,
but it's a pretty interesting story. So,
uh, he's like, why don't I just stick
a feather duster out my fucking ass?
You know? I mean, what
about acting? He's just,
he gets really upset and the
director says, forget it.
Forget it. Just, just to, to,
to it and we'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
So he goes and he does it again.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, it's fine.
We'll make it work. And, and after that,
that take, he goes over the Monitor,
he watches the play back and he comes
over to me and he says, listen man,
I'm sorry. Uh, you know, I'm on my,
literally on my knees all day and,
and these,
you understand what's going on with this
whole set up here. And it's just, I just,
I'm really sorry. You're
absolutely right. I'll do it.
I'll make them do another one if you
can. I'm like, no, no, it'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
So even he was getting sort of burnt
out by the whole, the whole experience.
And again, he was literally, you
know, on his knees the whole time.
Yeah. Oh, so, and as visual
effects you were doing, I mean,
did you have to do things in addition
to, to, you know, I guess, I don't know,
did they, like, did they green screen
his legs? Like, you know, like, uh,
you know, in Forrest Gump
where Gary Sinise was, was
that that kind of technique?
Yeah,
we didn't,
we didn't obviously quite out of the same
budget as Robert Zemeckis Forrest Gump.
But certainly we had,
I had wardrobe make
these leggings for him,
weren't super effective.
Again, cause you know,
not to get too into it but without locking
off the camera and they were shooting
a lot of a handheld or steady cam.
And so it was really a challenge and it
was essentially had to be done by hand
anyway. You couldn't really key out
the legs. It had to be done, you know,
frame by frame.
I mean there was another shot and I think
it's partially in the trailer to where
there, you know, he writes a trike too,
which I never, you know, who knows why.
It's like Peter Dinklage
is dating Patricia Arquette
and he rides a motorcycle.
And then, uh, Gary Rides this trike and
there was a scene where they show up.
It was a hotel out near West near lax,
uh,
where we were doing like this little
peoples of America convention.
And they show up and Gary has to get off
the trike and walk around and walk into
frame. And, uh, they also,
they had a really good double for him.
Like the hair was perfect that his
face was very similar. Um, you know,
a little person double and, and they were
debating how to do it. And I said, well,
let's, why don't you just have
him hide behind the trike?
Gary will step down and then this guy,
I'll walk around and then we'll cut to,
I mean it was just,
again,
we were sort of making it up as we went
along and there wasn't a great deal of
direction, uh, going on.
It was like I said, uh,
pretty crazy set.
Wow. I mean, uh, one of the things I've
been curious about, cause uh, I still,
like I said,
I haven't actually seen it,
we've just been obsessed
with this trailer and,
and I've actually played this for like,
I played it for Shawna Anders who directed
instant family that's out right now
and directed daddy's home. And he was
like, that's not a real thing. Right.
And I was like, what do you mean? He's
like, that trailer you were playing,
that's not real. And I go, yeah, it's
real. It's a real movie. And he was like,
no way. Like I, even when I showed it
to him, he was like, this is not a gag.
And I was like, no, no, no, this is real.
So we were reading trivia and like the
first trivia point that comes up says a
director, Matthew Bryant was
fired after he turned in his cut.
The whole film was then re edited.
Peter Dinklage has said the
original director's cut,
which screened in Austin was gorgeous,
but the people who fired
bright ruined the movie.
Do you know anything about that?
I do. I do. I know quite
a bit actually. I mean,
I'm sure Peter Dinklage has his opinion.
Uh,
I don't remember the whole
original director's cut.
I certainly saw the recut.
So they brought in, uh,
this well known editor,
Wendy Brickman,
who worked a lot with Ivan Reitman
has done a lot of bigger budget stuff.
Um, I had worked with her on
another project before and
so they brought her in to
try and find the movie. But you know, and
that's always the case in the editing.
But in this case, it was
really sort of, you know,
there was a lot of footage that I don't
think had any bearing on, you know,
the pro how the movie needed to,
to go.
And so I remember her talking to me
about it. Like, yeah, this was a,
it was a real challenge for her.
Um,
but certainly the sensibility
of Matthew Bright, uh,
was part of why everybody got involved.
I'm sure you know,
I don't know if you're aware of his,
his most famous movie is
a movie called freeway.
It was Reese Witherspoon's
first movie she plays,
she plays a girl hitchhiking to her
grandmother's house and Kiefer Sutherland
plays a character of Bob will Vinton,
you know, it's like this red writing.
I saw this movie,
I saw
crazy movie.
And so that was sort of
where he's established his
reputation as being, you know,
sort of a little bit out there and doing
interesting sort of cold kind of movies.
Um, but they certainly, I think they got
off the rails pretty badly. And in fact,
at one point after the
producers had taken over the,
the original editor and Matthew called
me because the movie got into Sundance
right?
As the original cut.
I think so, yes. Although
that's not what they showed a,
that's not what they showed.
So they, they, uh, uh, they
called me and they say, Hey,
listen, uh, you know, we know
you're still working for those guys,
but we want you to work for us too.
I'm like, okay, well, you know,
here's the budget. And they go, no, no,
no, we need you to do it for free. I said,
well, I can't really, I'm not sure how I
can, I mean, I'd love to help you. Like,
well, you gotta be on the side of the
filmmakers. I'm like, I really am,
but I can't pay you to work on this
movie for you either. And that,
that's where it ended. Like,
well, don't tell anybody we
called you. I'm like, well,
I don't know I can do that
either. You know? It was like,
it put me in a very challenging spot.
So did you see those showed up? Did
you see? Did you see two cuts though?
Did you see like a cut and
then a totally different cut?
So I saw something early,
but I don't know that that
was his cut necessarily.
But certainly I, I, well remember the
other cod in that there's, you know,
and again,
I don't want to spoil it for you.
I'm hoping it lives up
to your expectations.
I have a feeling it will no matter
what. Uh, but there's some big gaps.
It's just sorta jumps
across a few gaps that just,
I don't think they had anything
or anywhere to go with it. Um,
but to say that again, going
back to, you know, Peter's quote,
I say that the original cut was beautiful,
you know,
or whatever he exactly said, uh, no,
that it was a movie that
that could be gorgeous.
I don't know that it was a movie that
that could be shown that anyone would
understand.
Okay.
Showed up at Sundance by the way.
Matthew showed up because of course
Sundance really is on the side of the
filmmakers regardless
of who turns in the cut.
They invited Matthew and I remember he
got up on stage because I was there.
I was actually there with another movie.
Uh,
and he got up on stage and he called
the producers assholes with teeth.
Really?
At Sundance?
Yes it was. And they were all there. It
was in that big echo theater, you know,
the one of the biggest rooms.
And he said this right before
it screened or right after,
I think it was after.
Yeah. I mean Gary said,
uh, he said that, uh,
not my best role and it
didn't turn out well. Um,
do you feel like looking back, I mean,
you've worked on a bunch of things,
would you be like, oh, this is
the worst thing I worked on?
I wish I could say that was true,
but no. Wow. No, not even close.
I would say
there was a time when you could,
I mean it's Sorta true now,
Netflix and,
and all the streaming that you
can get a lot of projects made.
There's a great deal of
good projects being made,
but then you could sell a movie
foreign with a bunch of names.
Right?
I mean,
I worked on these movies that they would
have Joe [inaudible] and dawn Swayze
and Frank's put on the box.
They could put still alone
Swayze Esta Vez on the box.
And that's how they
would sell those movies.
And then they would build the blocks,
but they would feel the blockbuster
shelves with these, you know,
well intentioned movies. Everybody was, I,
everyone was trying to do their best
work. But yeah, you know, there's,
there's sometimes there's a reason people
rise to a higher level and the bigger
button,
it feels like a real
exclusive talent.
Seagal has really taken over
that space of, um, the, uh,
the $30,000, um, uh, action film.
Now he puts out like six a year.
I don't know if you've ever worked
on any of those, but he, he does. Um,
he does quite a bit of those films now.
No, I did a Chuck Norris movie, which
was a very interesting experience.
That was a movie called sidekicks.
Oh yeah.
Oh, a long time ago. That was a crazy,
where he was on set with like kids.
I think that's when he married the
nanny or something like that and uh,
don't pitch, oh, Kiss
Kapo was in that movie.
You know, it's, um,
I find that I find fascinating
about the visual effects thing too,
is like there's, there's like
these, these milestones or, or,
or,
or benchmarks that happen in,
in your guy's field that become,
it's like your brain recognizes
that, that's, you're like, oh,
that's,
that's what that,
when that capability was happening and
it can take you out of a movie or just
kind of make you go like, I dunno,
it, it throws you a little bit if, if,
if the effects are like super
dated or something, you know,
like there's a way you accept a
really old film. Like say you watch a,
you know, an old Hitchcock movie and you
see, you, you, you know that like, oh,
this is before modern day
visual effects. Right. And then
right. It'll be rear projection or it'll
be, yeah, paintings and stuff. Yeah.
So I would like someone falls off a
building and you're like, Ooh, that looks,
that looks bad.
The one that I feel like
has some years on it now,
but must have been,
uh,
after like some really modern capabilities
have held up for me is minority
report. Like it's at this point it's
gotta be over 10 years old. Right.
But a lot of those visual effects look
amazing. I know it was a huge budget.
They look amazing. But if you go
back probably 10 years before that,
if you watched the first Jurassic Park,
now that looks kind of wacky.
It looks wacky now.
Right?
Well we've gotten used to it being so
photo real and so convincing that even
though at the time our eyes were totally
accepting of those dinosaurs and the
quality and texture being
blown away, blown away, Ooh,
I can see where that's just, they're
not, that's not really there.
It's kind of fastener,
that minority report,
the guy that designed that set up
with the, with the glove and all that,
he went on to develop
that as a real thing.
What oblong and you can actually
go and do a demo with him.
He basically installs it in
like conference rooms and stuff.
Usually the CEOs and stuff that use it,
they like to use like a,
it's kind of like a, a ps four
controller or a controller. Uh,
but you can use the gloves.
It's got all these arrays above you.
And I've seen him do it. It's, it's
pretty remarkable where they're at.
This was a few years ago, but it's
impressive. They, they rewind some video,
they go back and forth
and do the whole thing.
The other one dog that takes me
out of the movie always throws me.
And because of the movie is otherwise
just like a perfect thriller.
Just such a great movie is the fugitive.
When Harrison Ford jumps off the train,
it,
it must have been like, I feel like
when you watch the movie, you're like,
this must have been the year before the
newer technology came out because it
looks so out of place. It looked so, like
we weren't even even a movie.
Like [inaudible] yes,
they're using a lot of
rear projection or process.
So there that shot, I think I'm, I'm,
I'm guessing that and even when he jumps,
you know, off the, uh, the, uh
damn and all that. Yeah. Uh,
I think a lot of that is
matte paintings and, and,
and process is somewhat old school.
They were probably
trying to marry in some,
some wire removal and that kind of
stuff with the old school stuff too.
And again, we eat, you know, if
it's old enough like you said,
it's totally acceptable,
but,
but when it's supposed to be right
and it just doesn't hold up. Um,
I mean there's a particular scene I
always think of, uh, in T2 where, uh,
they're on the bike and he jumps or
does something and it's so obviously,
you know, a screen behind him and
it's like, well, they, you know,
if it was good enough at
the time for James Cameron,
it must've been pretty freaking good.
Right. Yeah. It makes you go like,
that must have been the best available.
It's got it had to do it. Yeah,
absolutely. Um, Doug, I am an blankly,
sorry, go ahead. No, no, you go ahead.
I was going to say, and, and, and
frankly, back to tip toes, you know, the,
the ability for somebody
like me to do decent,
I would say probably not the absolute
best and there weren't a lot of shots that
made it, but decent work on
a workstation, um, you know,
on a really low budget is informed
by what all those guys did, you know,
going forward in terms of,
of the state of the yard.
And it's so it's trickled down to that,
you know,
almost anybody can afford some
pretty impressive tools now, uh,
to do really quality work. It's all,
all that's required is talent, you know,
but the machines are there,
they're really accessible.
And so that's why the quality has
gone up for everything. We look at it.
Yeah. Now the special effects are
insane, right? It's just like, uh,
it's unbelievable. What's,
what's, what's possible. Um,
I am really looking forward.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to pull the trigger and
I'm going to watch tiptoes. Um,
I really want to thank you for taking
your time and telling us a little bit
about it because this is,
um, it's really exciting.
So Doug socking.
Okay,
glad you found me. Of course. I really
appreciate your appreciation for it.
Uh, again, you know,
I'm still proud of working on these movies
to get to work with people like Gary
Oldman and Matthew mcconaughey.
Yeah.
It's really no matter what's going on
to see them work and to be around that
kind of a talent is always
impressive and enjoyable. And,
uh, like you said, you always
want it to be the best,
but if it winds up being this colt amazing
classic, that's cool too. You know.
That's cool. That's a great attitude. Um,
and thanks again for giving us some
insight on. I appreciate it, Doug.
Okay,
my pleasure, man. Take it easy.
Bye.
There was Doug sock in the
video effects producer,
uh, from tiptoes. Um, I got into
more than just tiptoes obviously,
but I enjoyed talking to him. All
right. Be Right back, uh, with, uh,
Christina after she's done taking a
shit. All right, well that was awesome.
Doug was so cool. You missed it. You were
taking your big dump. But Doug, Kathy,
a video effects producer
from tiptoes and uh,
you'll have to listen to it. It was, it
was pretty cool. I appreciate his time.
We're gonna switch it up now and um,
go into
a dark,
dark place with the darkest human being.
We know. All right ladies
time pull your panties up.
Going to be some redemption here
for the great. Josh Potter is
joining us. Hi. All the
ladies are Saturday.
I'm gonna make it better.
I think it's this intro.
I think it's the intro that's maybe
turning the female listeners off a little.
They don't like it. Do you think
we could get him a different intro?
What would you like?
Something that's like the dark
wave for something a little more.
Maybe not women crying and
being strangled. Strangled.
That's not what they're doing. What's
going on in there? Judge somebody?
Yeah.
No, not the intro. Josh.
This is the sweetest guy on the planet.
I feel like if you tell a Gif,
you tell like a nice
girl. Let's say you go, oh, a
potter's here. She would just go,
yeah.
Yeah. I don't know. I think
that's how they react when they,
it's like all the cute boys
went home and guess who's left?
Who's left? Me. Josh
Potter. Everybody. Okay.
Okay.
So you're not trying to rebrand myself
after last time. Let's talk about this.
So let's talk about it. So last time you
were here, um, and I ended up getting a,
that was a big episode.
A lot of downloads and a lot of feedback.
And here's the thing, you were,
um, you were actually saying,
I'll have to be honest.
It came as somewhat polarizing because
even though we're giving you the a hard
time about a lot of people being upset,
a lot of people really happy.
A lot of people will really, wow. Well,
sick people, some sick people out there.
They're also, they liked the sick jokes,
which I also like sick jokes. Sure.
Personally, what a was like. Foof
too much for me was just any,
because I'm a parent. The parent, the
kid stuff, I'm like, God dammit. No idea.
It doesn't make you laugh. No. But I'll
tell you what it did make me laugh.
What did make me laugh?
What I could've listened to nonstop was
just the stuff about Albert fish hurting
himself. Yeah. That
stuff made me how cute.
He was doing some wild stuff myself.
Like you said,
he put a nails and pins
into is a perennial. Yes.
He throw his taint in his
pelvis and then he, he would uh,
put a ro froze up his urethra
and one I forgot to mention. If
you want a little tidbit, I'm okay.
All good over here.
Okie doke.
So he's soaked cotton balls and alcohol
and then put them in his bum bum.
Yeah. And then he lit them on
fire now. That's funny cause yeah,
cause he's a creep so that's good.
Yes. Yeah. He likes that stuff.
What does that feel like?
So sick. Yeah. Was sick.
You know what I think it is? Look
at you. Look how happy you were.
Happy you weren't hearing
this kind of stuff. Well,
I think crazy stuff to yourself
is fun to laugh at it. I don't,
we always wanted to castrate himself but
couldn't bring him. God. I wish that,
yeah means him. Let me say, I like
that. He always want all of humanity,
but he couldn't bring himself
to do it. He never, uh,
was a a raper. Oh yes it
was. Nevermind. Nevermind.
My bad. I'll see. This is, you got me
back here today. You did. He look good.
My hair cut. I cut my face. Shaved it.
You look really handsome son. Josh.
Look great today. I'm warm in here. I
know you're turned down. Let's get this.
I think it's a perfect 77.
Actually it is hot in here and all
the lights and stabbed. Shot. Well,
you look great, Josh. Thank you. I
again, part of my rebranding, you know,
I don't want everyone to be scared.
I will. I'm not Albert Fish.
I just told you what I know.
So where do you think it went?
Like where did it go sideways on the last
one? What does that work? Well, I mean,
there are some people that were, I uh,
someone last night. Oh, sorry, go ahead.
Oh yeah. Freaked out. So I got a
number of messages and then in person,
somebody last night I ran to the comedy
store was like, Hey, uh, you know,
and I thought she was going to
bring up the thing that upset me,
which was like kid stuff. She was like,
when he was feeding people the pigs,
I and I go, even those were hungers.
Yeah. You know, they're not real.
Yeah. So, but anyways, I think it was just
too gruesome for some people. But again,
I were leaning on that.
I have to be fair a lot people were
saying that they thought
Josh was hilarious,
but nevertheless it was a polarizing
segment, which is always a good thing.
You know, we're stirring up
debate, getting attention,
but Josh isn't here. He says,
you know what? I'm going to redeem
myself. I won't keep to have a good time.
I want,
I want to have a segment now about love.
It's all about love.
I thought that I would share with
you some of the best sex toys.
Oh Wow. Because it's the holidays. It's
about to be Valentine's days. True.
That's true.
You need to like,
I dunno if you guys need maybe something
in your life. This is actually our, uh,
our new year's episode we're doing
right now. So this is perfect. Uh,
start off the new year.
This will be coming out the evening of
the first on audio and this on the second
on video.
So this is a what a great way to start
off your perfect time to prepare for
Valentine's Day times. Oh,
you're saying it wrong.
You're saying my goodness, I'm so
sorry. But uh, yeah, so I thought,
and maybe you guys can take some tips
with you if you need to like spice. Hey,
we're 10 years married,
so yeah,
I mean it's time you just had your
anniversary and that Christina has been
talking about BBC is quite a bit lately.
Uh,
I think you know what it means
to be British broadcasting.
What'd you see? What'd you start looking
at? What'd you lick your chops at?
The Lakers. Really? Yes.
I wish one not licking my chops.
She was looking at shops also about
who she was like, she was like,
guess what? This is the next morning.
She goes, I had a dream last night.
I was like, okay. She goes that
you had a big black cock. Oh,
don't you did. I'm proud of is my
therapist. She goes, just curious.
Do you have any, I mean you had
any dreams lately and I go, what?
As a matter of fact,
yes.
I've had two about my husband and
I have a nice way of phrasing it.
It's not really about your husband,
it's about something else. No.
When I told her I go and he had a big
black dog, she didn't laugh. She was like,
no. She was like, that's interesting. And
then the one that my husband was to go,
I went to the Laker game and then I had
full disclosure and she didn't
judge it. Oh, that's nice.
She said it's an it's anxiety
related [inaudible] about you,
about not having a big
enough dick and your life.
Tom With Bronze Dick,
I don't know if it's Lebron's sick,
but it was a big black tech like we were
doing it and everything about him was
himself except for this guy.
Wasn't Lonzo ball's
I could have been d wade is,
he wasn't the guy. That's true.
What a game or Ingram. He's probably
got a hog on him. No. So wait did,
she was just so many black. The game.
I was like, there's so many black dudes
at a basketball game. Uh, so she's sharp.
But can you tell us or is
it private? No, it's, it's,
it's more related to anxiety honestly.
Then sexual preference. Yeah.
How has it really,
I mean I'll tell you because I um,
I have a lot of dreams that I'm back in
time or that my life isn't the life I
have now and it's related to
anxiety, anxiety, anxiety.
Because I'm having anxiety actually about
you traveling soon cause you're going
to be traveling and that's what it is.
Just all players travel
related to like I'm leaving a lot
and a black guy will fill in for him.
Then a big black black Mamba will
come in and do his thing. That's cool.
That's the black black Mamba. Yes. He's
not on the team anymore. She's like,
are we going to see Coby tonight? And I'm
like, it's been years since he retired.
Like he is the vet.
All the BBC she's never asked
me was for sports immediate.
She's like, when can we go to another
Laker game? Basketball's fun. Yeah, they,
it's just the bbcs maybe it
is to be swinging bs. When
you said go back in time,
I was like to when slavery,
but you meant your life.
Gosh, you are Jesus Christ.
So, uh, so okay. So sex toys.
I don't have BBC on my list too
badly or I have three folders.
I haven't opened them on purpose. Is there
one I should start with? Right. Okay.
So there should be one labeled for her.
I've picked up for her and to,
for him my favorite of the
year, if you will. So okay.
And then we'll go on to a new different
category, but we'll start with for her.
Okay. Here we go. Open it
up and open the first. The
chronological. Yeah. Here we go.
Keep in mind ladies and Christina,
the this. This is free choice.
Here we go. Ooh. Now what do you think?
That fucking,
even one that's really interesting.
This is the bumpy Betty tongue vibe throw
up and it is in the shape of a tongue.
I see that it almost looks like it
could be a miniature shoe for a genie,
like a child has a little
tip, but it looks like a
tongue with sores on it. Yeah,
it does.
It's like an infection that is the special
edition to the tongue that I thought,
I mean we all like bumps on our tongues,
right?
It's like if we're going
to have a tongue in us,
I thought for a second you meant that's
how they're marketing it. They're like,
it's a gonorrhea tongue.
Doesn't it feel dangerous?
That could be the way that's,
maybe that's the extra added bonus for it,
but it does make you curious like, hey,
maybe I should try a gonorrhea tongue.
This one feels so darn good.
Yeah.
It's just like the state of the art.
This is the latest and greatest kind
of thing. This is the yes. Now it's,
it's no longer dildos that are dicks.
They also make them in tongue form
because the tongue is the new dick.
Everybody. Yeah, I'll skip.
Dick went after her. In fact,
before you play the show,
the next image,
oftentimes you see a apparatus that
is like a strap on for the chin,
right? Yeah. The chill though. Yes.
That way you can have a fake
dick with a real tongue. Well,
this one puts that on its head.
Oh,
whoa. Here you can get a
real dick with a fake tongue.
Oh,
so you're Ding Dong is going through this
whole precisely and then that is up at
her.
Hello?
Her BombBomb or maybe
you put it at her hood.
It's versatile tops or her butthole.
Yes.
If you want your butthole
scraped, what do you think? Well,
I'll tell you what I think. I think
it's a good theory. It's good in theory.
However, this, these look sharp. Well,
that's just also have an image though.
I doubt. Really sharp. They were.
They were down after use. You know,
they become less, you know, they get
you to try. If you had to have the two,
we've seen the first one. I'm afraid
of the sharpness of the, yeah,
they're not going to be sharp.
It's just the, it's just the look.
I think it's the light hitting the nubs.
Not really. Probably very similar to the,
to the grumpy. You'd probably put
those things on your bud hall.
I'll put them on your butthole. No,
your buttle. I would put, by the way,
because I don't have a scrum meter
in my life, I would use this.
I put this that's very
well. Scrum dot. Yeah.
That's something that
grown dog millionaire.
That's something that it could be for
him as well. I suppose you're right,
but on the other, on the other
one, you could even take that,
turn it inward on yourself
because it vibrates on the weight.
On the tongue. Yeah. Yeah. You know
what I'm saying? Like you could bring,
give it a shot, bring it
into your, painted it black.
Would you give it a shot?
No. Liquor colors. You have to dig
gold. Let me ask you something.
You could do that. That's a
cock ring too, right? Yeah.
You can put that on your cock ring and
then point that without my cock rewards.
But you put on the cock ring.
I put on the Cochrane. Yes.
Well I've been trying to teach
you English. I can't tired.
And then you turn that part around
with the, the tongue bits on your tank.
Tickle your own. I reached behind your
bag. We'll do something, you know,
something be on there on your
scrub. You know, it might,
it might nuzzle the bag, which we
feel a nice lodge. Something loose.
You don't know. That's true. You know, I
could be into that. Now for the gentlemen,
I have made a selection. Okay. Uh, okay.
This now before you show it,
have you ever thought this
sex doll has too many pieces?
Do we really need the armpit
of the SEC style? Right, right.
And then storage I, it's
like, I don't even have that.
I don't have like really that big of
a gap between under my bed. Right.
Where do you keep all
full woman? Right. True.
So this company has come up with a
design that is way more efficient.
Okay, let's look at Chi. Oh whoa.
What the fuck it is all the best parts
of the woman in one compact area.
My guy can slide this under the couch.
You can put it under the bed.
This is depravity, the bottom.
And I'm not liking
the fact cause I tell you why.
Why is that?
It looks too small.
It looks features look kind of childlike.
They don't look like,
like I see, I see a doll.
You know what I mean?
It was like a doll.
I'm more disturbed by the
vagina slit with the, the,
the two tits is amen to that.
That's the best thing.
If you ask me, I face looks like a
misprint. Yeah. And I don't know, my,
my mind didn't jump to child because
like what Sean has tits like that.
I mean Geez, I mean a couple of lucky
ones. But what I was thinking was just,
but I mean I love the
ingenuity of giving you the,
first of all the nose is just be like
this is a face. Yeah. But I mean,
have you ever gotten blown
by a noseless person?
Never the weird person.
I mean the, the tits are kind of the eyes,
which is kind of Nice from that angle.
Exactly what I tip.
Do you love about men in general?
Sometimes you guys are just no frills.
This is such a no frills sex toy.
That's great.
It's just like all the important
bits, Matt. I mean, like I said,
where would you store this is
pretty hot. I would get this. Yeah.
Which one are you buying though?
They're the same thing
now. You know what it's missing
though. What is a be whole,
if I were to read it,
if I were to redesign this side
would have to be whole for me.
I think they want to leave
you wanting more. Oh,
they did version to the next model
will come fully furbished with a deal.
Now you mentioned the mouth and how
creepy it is. I always feel like it's, um,
these things have to be so nasty after it.
I never understood why. Did you ever
try a flashlight? Ever? Because I can't,
I don't have enough mental strength to
then clean my own ges out of it and like
put it in the dishwasher or whatever,
you know,
like how they make that
real normal in there. Oh,
just scraping by on just outta
here. Cleaning. Throw it here,
put it next to your coffee mug and go
about your day cleaning lady. Do it. Yeah.
Yeah. No, I uh, I like the, the,
just to disappear in some capacity
immediately almost, you know, whether,
yeah.
Do you guys feel repolish then when
you have it out of you leave your body,
you're kind of like, Eh, I'm a different
person, you know? Oh, the poisons gone.
It's out there. Yeah. It does
change you completely. 100%.
It really does. I mean it,
it is like David banner again.
Oh cause it Bruce banner did you get
backed up for number of days too and you
start getting short,
you know,
and just like, yeah, it's a
total, okay. I'm more of like,
when it's out of me, I'm like, Oh
God, I'm terrible person. You know,
like that kind of the shame.
And I have that too.
I have that from a strong
Catholic upbringing. Yeah. Yeah.
Mine's not a Catholic thing. I don't know.
It's just I hate myself thing. I think.
Isn't that fascinating though?
If it's not like I always thought that
mine was tied to that, that like, um,
and I feel that shame more alone,
you know?
Like I don't feel it after exacerbate
your spelling, your seed. It's in the,
it's like the moment after it's
done, I'm like, I'm a bad person.
I have had that where I say like that
where I feel like I'm like, oh, I'm grown.
I'm a gross person. Then when it's
with a woman, I'm like, Oh God,
she's regretting this snap. You know what
I'm saying? Yeah. I'm a little patriots.
I'm sorry. Yeah. That's the first way
things up. Yeah. That's so interesting.
It's just self-loathing.
Maybe by yourself. Pleasure.
You think it's shameful,
I guess. Yeah. I, I've always tied
it to the Catholic guilt. Sure.
Because in our house too, it was
really bad. Like sex was, it was like,
Duh, that's not even like a topic
you need to discuss. Not a reality.
Like it was that crazy where you're like,
wow, we're really pretending this hard.
Yeah.
You know,
and my mom would be the type that like
if you're watching TV or a movie and a
woman were to walk on screen in
a bikini at a, on a beach scene,
it would be like you're watching
pornography. Like she wouldn't be kidding.
Cause like, what is this? I'm
like, it's a fucking PG 13 movie.
But you know all that stored up when
your spank bank. I think so. Yeah.
They fight each other.
That's interesting.
I've never felt like shame about that
kind of thing. It's always just been,
like I said, I'm like, this can't be fun
for her, you know, that kind of thing.
Really. And then after I, if it's
just masturbation, I'm just like,
I am gross. Have you
smashed lately dude? No, no,
it's been,
that's part of it is because I'm just
like living in the sewers of life right
now. You know what I'm saying? Really?
Yeah, Dude. I've definitely, like,
I walk the street at night like, really?
Yeah. I like, what are you doing? No,
I'm just getting, I don't know. It's
dangerous. It is though. But no, I,
I mean like, you know, just ride the
subway a lot. Yeah. And you're just, uh,
I'm not in a world where there's women,
I don't know where they are.
I have to go to a club. I'm not going
to go there, you know? Yeah. No,
you don't need to be,
I'm waiting to find them where I go.
Do you ever do the online thing
at all? Never. I have, but I mean,
I'm not good at it.
You know,
we just had a session with Kyle
Dunnigan right over his profile.
You're, you would probably be great at
it if you had one. Now. What the fuck?
Why do you know so much? I
was wondering. It's intuitive.
It is intuitive and I just don't have
that ability. Well, here's the thing.
If it was all faceless,
I would crush because I can
talk and text pretty great.
Yes.
Now the way to get in with those people
is they have to swipe on you. Yeah.
So they just see what I look like and
I'm like already, but here's the thing.
Coming from behind. Yeah. Okay.
Here's the thing about that.
You think that and you go like, you
know, I'm not a 10 or whatever. Right.
But if you take, you know,
you get cleaned up, you know,
I get that part of it. You're going
to get some people swept to me.
I know I'm not like destitute,
but I'm not fucking Zac Efron
here and we just chicks they,
why don't we just play the numbers
though? I swipe. That's what I do.
I swipe right on everything, see what I
get, and then I sort it out later. Okay.
You aren't doing it. Sometimes I stopped
doing it. Oh, okay. One second. Can we,
can we jump? You want to reactivate it
and also Josh too. You're, you're not,
you're a good looking dude.
And here's what you need to do though.
All you gotta do is it's fashion.
Like, look, this is good.
This is definitely better.
Really. Well, yeah.
You didn't know that I came in here
specifically to look creepier than normal
shit. Well, that backfired. Yeah,
no, that's what it looks good,
but it's really accessorizing
properly for dudes.
Like some access meaning just to see.
Of course you go with,
I have a far right one. Oh,
you wish the phone line. Well,
um,
I'd like to see what photos you choose.
Maybe you can bring us up. I have no good
photos. Did it pick up? No, that's it.
Now I hear it. I'd like to see.
Let's get some good photos.
The right clothes put up are what?
Three or four best photos?
See what I mean?
You can handle the profile.
Let's just look at the image and then
let's do a swipe right. Experiment.
Let's see. Okay. I say
we do it in the new year.
We get him I'm game and then a
full report. Sex toys on them.
I also fear maintaining
like the putting up of EHRs.
Like what if I regressed to my
ability, my lack of abilities? No,
and you know what? I'm still going
to be motivated fashion wise.
You're going to be motivated. We're
going to motivate, will motivate you.
All right, I'm down. Let's do it. Let's
find him a lady in 2019 even down,
even down to do this. I'll take
you shopping. All my God. Wow.
That's cannot be exclusive.
It could be the cameras and yeah, we
could do that. That would be dope. Yeah.
Yeah. I would love to see what I'm aiming
wrong. My pickers are on for clothes.
I think you, you need to
smell the group. Yeah.
What is the, uh, you want to go back? Go
back to the first image. Okay. One moment.
You brought up the creepiest
part here. Yes. This mouth.
Yes. Well, it's like, it's,
you know what it is that I was wrong
by saying what I'm saying is it,
it looks kind of like a doll
and dolls to me are, you know,
I think of children's. Yeah.
It doesn't look human enough.
Is that what you're saying? Well, it's
just like, uh, uh, if you were to take a,
if you go to pick up a doll right now,
but that's the image that I
have is like those, you know,
there's a specific way that the, the lips
layers doll. Well, this might help you,
uh,
go to image too,
and this might change your mind about
your accuracy of the mountain. Okay.
Oh,
okay.
I think you're right.
I don't see a dollar anymore.
Yeah.
It looks like
it looks like you're doing it the way
your picture isn't it. Yeah. First of all,
I didn't really,
that looks like a toms arm that
looks like a fucking aggressive, ah,
move.
And for our listeners is the same,
uh,
I guess apparatus apparatus and that
little mouth has obviously very pliable,
um, well, because it has an opening
for your, your penis to enter.
But the person pulling the lip up,
showing you to grasp because there
they're pulling it pretty far off.
Yeah. Like face. And you see that there's
teeth in there. Yeah. Go to image three.
If you want to get a better look at it.
Ugh.
Set of teeth and nice. Yeah. Now,
which just goes to show a Tom
with these guys, these videos,
and they're according women and
they don't even have their teeth.
The teeth are very important in the
human cording process. Taught your dog.
Didn't know how the dall teeth would
become important. Maybe you just want,
it's just a mental thing.
Maybe she takes care of herself.
You know that she's a cleaning lady.
We want it. We want to come so badly.
I know it's so gross.
Or just like make a fucking
torso with tits and ass hoes.
You did bring up the lack of eyes. Teeth
are there. The teeth are there. I mean,
what do you think if you walk into a
guy's place and you see that red flag,
you would rent Albo red flag,
red flag, like need to marry.
What is the message? I think this is
desperation. Definitely. Really? Yeah.
I kind of don't mind a flashlight. I
don't think that's a bad thing. Yeah.
That's interesting that you're like,
oh that guy is just getting off.
Because I think the spookiness of this
thing where it's like, I want a mouth,
I want a slit and I want tits
and that's it. It's like, well,
why not just go look for the whole doll?
Like if someone had a whole dall I'd be
okay with that. Oh, sorry. No fuck though.
I mean I bring up again storage story
because this thing is what's great about
this product. They listen
to their customers. Yes.
What's great about this product is that
you wouldn't have someone like Christina
coming over and happening upon it.
Right.
Unless they're snooping about
because you can keep very Nazi.
Do not snoop. Yeah, no,
I'll keep that in your
call Josh so that men buy it.
Go ahead.
If they want to ever have a real woman
through that, through that one over there.
It is the concubine breast stall I
believe is why concubine those dolls,
those real dolls. The first of all for
last I heard there were about $10,000
and they're very heavy.
I know a lot of women who will do the
things those dolls do for $10,000 is all
I'm saying. Maybe not
forever, but you know,
sessions at a robot would be ideal as I
wonder if that's going to happen anytime
soon. Yeah, that would be really,
I'm scared of that cool whole thing.
Now I know you to like the fancier
things in life sometimes. Sure.
So I thought let's find some of the
best sex toys to share with you.
Oh, fancy toys. Yes. Fans.
The fanciest of toys.
And that's what's in this next folder.
Yes. So you can bring up the first one.
Okay, here we go. Now this one, oh my God,
this is a silver,
but plug horse tail that
is 100% authentic horsehair
Verone play. This is for, well, it depends
on what you want. I mean, are you a brony?
I don't know.
This I don't think is up the bronies
alley because it's black and it's silver
and cold and,
and uh,
it's not really the brony speed.
It's more if you want to be like a Viggo
Mortensen and he'll dial go or some
shit. You know what I'm saying?
Like it's a little more angle.
I mean also by the way,
it looks like there's some real
handiwork in the butt plug aspect here.
I rolled it is made of actual silver.
Do we have a cost on this? D I was going
to ask, would you like to guess? Oh,
hold on.
Now you're telling me that this is real
horse hair cracked and real silver.
Okay. Because I know in the we've market
when you get like clip ons for women or
extensions in your hair,
human hair costs a God damn fortune.
So if you're going real hair at any
capacity, I imagine it's quite expensive.
So I'm going to estimate,
I'm going to go real hair that I'd say
this 609 and then real surreal silver 12
$1,200 wow.
It's pretty good.
Guess I'll guess more 1650 you guys are
going real high and now this one is in
the thousands but it's a
retailed at $3,475 oh my God.
3000 for this.
Oh,
you were doing hundreds when you said
that. I thought you said 16,000 no,
1600 oh no, no, no, no.
It is 3,470 I thought you were going.
Wow. No, no, no.
3,475 law.
That is an investment
where it all the time though. You know, I,
and I mean this like what's the
point of a butt plug? Like I said,
I think it just feels good
to have it always in there.
I don't know about always.
Not always I guess.
I think it probably a couple of things
probably feels good to some people to
just have it resting in and
out, in and out. You just know,
just pop it in his pocket and then you
will also go in the other way. Right.
One and the pink one and the state.
Yes. There you go dog. But um,
but the other thing is this could also
get you ready if you're going to take on
some other things and I don't know
what you mean. In other words,
you put the bumps one again to
start. Yeah, start stretching.
So you go like I'm running this train,
the Lakers are in town,
they're all going to get in here. I
need to loosen it up an appetizer. Yeah.
Yeah. That's your, your, your bum
hole. Just going like, oh, okay.
We're playing ball today. Like
stretch. Sure, sure, sure,
sure, sure, sure. Exactly.
Yeah. Cause it gets bigger as it
gets kind of v shaped, if you will.
And then when the first dawn comes in,
your butthole is like, okay. All right,
we're ready. Yeah. It's like stretching
before you run. Gotcha. The warmup. Yeah.
Gotcha,
Gotcha.
And in this case it has a little fun to
it so you can twirl it in your fingers
or you can, you know,
lift it up. It's true.
Give a little space. Yeah.
You can prance around.
Get up thing an oats around your head.
Equine diarrhea.
So the next item, what is this next
item? This next item is the, uh,
the tally Ho chair. Uh Huh. Should
I bring it up? I'm terrified.
What? Fuck is this? What is that?
You guys can't picture multiple
ways to talk sex on this tally.
Ho Chair. Well, this is a
premier sex chair. Yeah.
Is that like crocodile skin or something?
It is a,
I don't know what it's actually,
I don't know the upholstery,
but it is blood designed by Marc
brassier Jones who does furniture.
I'm sure you've heard of. Uh, I see,
I see a doctor sitting here and eating
someone's box or something here at the
end. Right. You're like, there's one way.
Am I okay? And Robert, Robert, Robert,
all wrong.
There's a myriad of positions you can
take with you that I was pregnant.
And then the doctor is like, I got to
check, make sure everything's all right.
And he's like here that I always saved
this for the ninth month and he unzips
and then he puts it in there. He's
like how everything feels. All right.
What are those called? Cep. The lameness
subset. Speculums yeah. Oh yeah. My,
my Dick has to work this
time cause my spec was broken
and I skinned
so stupid.
So people purchase these and they have
sex in various positions that you can't
have an a bed. Apparently I
see the curves and um, oh yeah.
I mean this second little
stepladder. Yeah, that's kind
of, that's how you get it.
You can put your hands here when the lady,
you can get in the door in your hands.
There you go. Upwards, right? Oh yeah.
One thing I'm not really feeling real
freaks. Yeah. Using this thing. Got It.
You come up with a whole different
things when a bed just isn't enough.
Our couch or a sink or a floor or a
hammock or a million other things you need
to buy a specific piece of furniture to
fuck on, but the one that I don't like,
I'd not feeling this material because
it reminds me of hell raiser hell bound
hell raiser to when the
people were skinless,
it was red and you know what I'm saying?
It's like snake skin or or like you know,
red is not the cup type of reptile.
To me that just looks like it's going
to be the kind that like you're sweating
and sticky. It does not seem
for us than inviting. Yeah.
Perhaps your mind will change when you'll
know that this is the actual sex chair
from 50 shades of gray.
Oh,
I'm such a big fan.
I've read every book that day.
They come out now retail price on that.
Oh,
knowing that fact. Well knowing
that it's from that film, okay,
that's going to be bonkers.
I would almost say that they should tell
you the price without it having been in
the film. True. The price it was made
specifically for the, for that film.
It's richer designer. No, no,
hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hold on. That six figures.
This is only the second highest
priced item that I have.
So hold on, hold on. This,
what material is this leather. They don't
tell us. You didn't tell us that? No,
I don't. Oh, the finest of, Oh,
the finest of sex chairs. Uh,
it is made. That is snake
snakes get, so that's,
that's where the cost is going to be.
And because it's a costume,
we can't mass produce something that
is in this hugely successful franchise.
Cachet of that horse. Shit. Okay.
Uh,
$37,000 no. What? Okay. Okay. Hold
on, hold on. Okay, let me think.
Snake skin.
I'm going to go nine,
$999 okay.
Wow. Okay. It is $14,615.
Oh my God. There you go.
For a fuck toy. Yeah.
I mean you were really in
the cheap land get, I mean,
this is only the second tiered.
We're moving up now. Okay.
Oh my gosh. Okay. You said that.
So let's just, sorry. So get ready.
Shit against time. Ready? You
can, you can bring it up. Um, no.
These fucking dumb things. Do you know
what those are Ben Wa balls. They are,
I'll tell you something though.
I don't know a single woman on the
planet that's ever really used these,
put them in their pussies.
Hey,
you're supposed to put them in your
pussy then like rock around rocking the
chair. It's, well,
it's four key eagle exercises.
Yeah.
And maybe you'll change your mind after
you'll know that these are made out of
solid gold. Wow. Oh Wow.
And not only that,
the creators guarantee that you will
not get them stuck inside your body.
How that's on the, that's
on there. I don't know.
How do we know how much they weigh? I
don't know how much they weigh. Shit.
That would have been quite a carat gold.
Let me,
here's always the problem with
all the gold baby is that they,
I don't know a single woman on the planet
that's ever been in and really you've
never been done? Not One. What about a man
buddy? Somebody listening has done this.
Of course right now someone is listening
and doing it. I'm asking you if you are,
let me know.
Please let us know or they're listening
to our show now and using them as
they're listening. Sure. How else
would you work out? Key goals. Oh,
you can do right now doing it right now
and I got both.
Then you can hear him.
The problem is getting them out.
I imagine now that you can just push
and they probably will come out. Um,
push them out. Um, I'd be a little
scared of having loose things in there.
What about a boy? Do you think you could
keep all this up pal up my booty hole?
Some gold up your butt if I
wanted to really train those
muscles. Yeah. Hell yeah.
And you can do it for a mere price
of gold oil out auto. Three grand.
Oh wait, you said it's bigger than
the more, it's more so it's more,
what was the last one?
The chair 14 fuck 2020,
19 uh,
19 six to be exact.
Yeah. In 20 g's on some gold balls for
your blessing. That's a big flex, right?
You get on Instagram, be like,
got my 20 grand pussy balls.
He was from my key goals. My girl's
pussy. He's got all types of gold.
His side of it. Tommy. Yes.
Would you close out our son's college
fund and buy me these? I would love to it.
I want to do 'em for Ya.
Just for wanting to be covered in gold.
I want to do this for us as a couple
while you sit down and you tell him, okay,
what do you do this easy?
You tell him.
It was like when he's a
senior in high school,
you go your father and I want to tell
you something and then he's like, okay,
and you're like sit down and then
you reach down and you poop them out.
I go and then you can put them on the
table and you roll them over to him.
And he's like, what the fuck
is this? And you're like,
that's your college education
fund. And he's like, what is this?
It's mom's gold pussy balls.
And he's like, I love you mom.
Or you can wait even longer.
And then when you pass on the
lawyers reading your son the will,
there you go, even better. And he
said, your mother and father left.
You're nothing except the one for each
$10,000 per Ellison Julian.
Great.
It should get one of mommy and daddy's
Ben Wa balls. I could fit more than two.
I think two is, especially
with your new, uh,
lane of entertainment
that you're into them,
you're going to be fitting six times
out of that. And they're, yeah,
I've had two children. You know,
the clippers are in town too.
Um,
now this final item [inaudible] my Lord.
Now this one is definitely something
that you'll want to invest in. Oh my God.
And a leave to your children
for generations to come.
This is a big King Cobra Cock ring.
Oh my God.
Oh, this is a cock ring.
That is a cock ring.
It takes over 100 man hours to craft what?
Yes.
Is it made of real two made out of gold
as well. Well how do you, how do you,
I mean this is, this is another
flex move it sounds like. Yes.
100% and it gives you energy
having that snake on your,
your cock energy that you can't
even quantify with things out money.
I feel like you're really
good spokesman for them. Yeah.
Now if only you found out the price of it.
One question though, cause a cock ring,
you have to kind of sized to you're Dong,
we've made that mistake before. So, um,
well how would you know
that it's true? I don't, I,
I'm not certain I feel like they would
have it a hundred a hundred man hours
takes a lot.
So you would have to order it.
Probably give them the dimensions of
your penis and don't say the wrong size.
Yeah. Give him the real, the real size.
Talked about my dream today. Yeah.
My therapist. She goes, so the dream
about the black penis, she said penis.
I said, dawn, she usually
mirrors my language to use that.
You use juvenile word talk about it
Dong right. That's what I'm saying.
But she mirrored, usually she
mirrors back to me with my language,
but she referred to it as a
penis. Yeah. I just remember that.
I had to say a sentence
says Dick. I was like, Ooh.
But she was English as a second language,
you know,
so I was kind of like
laughing and then I was like,
Dick,
I think you'd have to change the species
of snake for depending on the dog,
obviously. Oh, I see. What do you mean?
Like that's a, that's a cobra for you.
The one you're discussing,
you probably need like an Anaconda.
Still bigger snake. You know, if you're
going to get fit Lebron and his buddy,
you're going to need a bigger snake.
Yeah.
It's like Good Morning King Cobra going
to be like this neck thinks he's are a
bunch of other snacks. I
Dunno if it's gonna work, man,
you're going to need about six snakes
now.
How much you think this fella costs
here? Fuck. Oh Shit. That's, I mean,
that could be anything.
That could be like 40 grand.
It's not the most. It is
the most expensive. Oh, it
is the most expensive. Oh,
okay. Shit. A hundred man hours,
gold cock ring.
Where'd you find this?
This is the silliest thing I've
ever heard of in my life. Um, okay.
That's a silliness. Uh,
I'm going to go with a
$35,000 and your guests,
I'm going to go higher on this one 40.
It is $120,000.
There are some details missing on this
thing. What the fuck, man? What else?
Is there a rubies, gems and diamonds
in there? The a hundred man hours dog.
Look at that. Craftsmanship.
I know, and the materials
I just figured and they haven't sold many.
That's a true 120,000 yes. Yeah.
You're definitely giving them the,
the specs on your dog. You have to,
but the cock ring, first of all,
the fact that gold is hard, so it's not
comfortable. Do you know what I mean?
It's heavy. I'm assuming
it's cold. Powerful.
It's like not a good material for
a cock ring. Right. Hard gold.
You know what I'm saying? The way that
they positioned to sell it is it's, uh,
it's first special occasions,
obvious, so obvious,
and you can wear it all day to really
feel that power. You can just keep it. Oh,
I see. You're saying. Yes. So it doesn't
stay cold. You know, it's not just like,
you're not just going to
wear this all the time.
You're putting it on your Dick in
the morning. You're going to work.
You're calling people on the phone being
like, buy, sell, buy, sell, and then your,
your Dick. You just feel the energy
from it, the whole, right. I see. I see.
That's why it's a real boss moved on now.
I like that.
Now I feel like we have to invest in it
as a gold snake hog ring for it. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a good, it's a really
good idea. That's your agent.
We're going to book you a Gig so you
can do it. I gotta get this cock ring.
Anything you can do.
How can I get an extra
hundred and $20,000 crazy?
Who would spend that on a cock ring? I
don't know. Somebody Sultan of Brunei.
Actually it might even be Lakers.
There might be like he's playing with it
right now. Yeah, they probably play it.
We might've. That's true. You know what
they're like, we haven't sold many.
I bet you fucking half of them
went to some NBA guys. Yeah,
they have a lot of disposable
income. That's true. Um, uh, Josh,
you definitely redeemed yourself.
That was a fantastic thank
Josh and then a new song.
Thanks for having me.
We really need to make that happen.
It just feels like a college party.
All right. Jesus. Alright. Yeah, right.
Really great segment with Josh.
That was great.
I feel like he really brought it home.
He really redeemed himself on that one.
Well, I mean, what do you think? Certainly
nothing wrong with the last time either.
I know you really were laughing about it.
Uh,
I want to bring to everyone's attention
a discussion and argument we had the
other day. Yep. You often mispronounced
things make can wait. Can I say why?
Yes. Because I was raised by
two Hungarian parents. Yes.
And they were learning English and
they taught me how to speak English.
That's true.
So it's funny because it will carry on
to people who didn't speak correctly.
We'll teach you and then you will
have it go on through your life.
42 years. You're a native
English speaker. Not True.
I spoke Hungarian first and then
I learned English all right.
At the same time as my parents did well,
I realized the big difference
is that my mother, uh,
mispronounces a lot of things,
there's a lot of things incorrectly,
but I always had the balance
of my father was American,
so he taught you the right
way and it would just stand
out clearly. I'm like, oh,
she's saying that completely incorrectly
and this person will balance it out.
And also also in my
defense, Tom. Yeah, yeah.
I was an avid reader growing up. Okay.
No, I read a lot of books. However,
I didn't always know how
to say those words aloud,
so I knew I knew how to read them.
But I didn't know how they were spoken.
So that's another problem.
What was funny to me was that we got
into this conversation about a word I'll
bring up momentarily,
but what's interesting is that I actually
thought was what's interesting to me,
I actually thought you were
pronouncing it a foreign way,
her announcing it or pronouncing it.
I actually thought you were
pronouncing it a foreign way.
It turns out you are actually pronouncing
it the way supposedly Americans
pronounce it.
Even though I,
I swear I hear it more
said the British way.
So the word is the word that I'm,
it's the full word, the that comes
from, if you were to say mini,
what's the full word?
Miniature.
You say miniature.
Miniature because I am pronouncing,
it's spelled m. I. N. I.
A. T. U. R. E. Yeah. I've,
I've hung out with some weird people,
but I've always heard people
say miniature miniature.
And it turns out the way that I'm used
to saying it is how the Brits would say
it meant a Cha.
They say miniature.
And that's what I said and I
thought you were such a weird,
weird person,
you know?
So the Americans say miniature,
but I swear more Americans that I've
had conversations with pronounce it the
British way. Miniature. I agree.
I I,
I've heard it spoken both ways.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
sure.
I want her to do all our
sure announcement. Yeah.
This is the American flag here,
man.
Let us know that this is an
American way of saying it.
I still think it sounds so stupid.
I am only ever thought of it as miniature.
I've only,
I swear to you miniature was the first,
the first time that it ever caught my
attention was with you in bed when you're
like, oh, like a miniature one.
I was like, wait, what the fuck?
I've only ever said or her miniature.
Miniature. None. That's
interesting though,
because you'd think that the British
pronunciation is mini at Cha. Exactly.
Which is why I accused you of saying
it the British way. Correct. Yeah.
I was thinking, oh, the phonetic
pronunciation must be the British way.
Correct us as Americans are saying,
like,
I was thinking that my pronunciation,
it must be the dumb American
adoption of it miniature,
but it's the other way around.
Let me tell you another one that had
just occurred to me that I'd like to
investigate right now. Okay. Now, when
I lived in England for a year, yes,
they would always say the phrase,
rightly so and rightly so
and rightly so right now.
I don't know if in the US, cause
I've said, yeah, rightly so. And I,
and someone goes, you mean
rightfully so? And I'm like,
I'm not sure which one's correct.
Is it right?
Felisa or rightly so and
rightly sounds more correct to,
to me rightly so. Yeah. Would you look it
up? Is it rightly so? What do you think?
Or rightfully so.
Um,
rightly so and rightly so.
I think rightly so.
But a lot of people think of rights.
Here's what it says you
want to here it says
in good uses rightly is the
opposite of wrongly, right?
Rightfully means much the
same as by rights and saying
rightfully the announcer.
Oh, is, okay. So it's making that
distinction. Does that make sense to you?
Say it again? Um, right. Oh,
meaning once pertaining to one's rights.
Yeah,
the rightful owner and
rightly Karoly spoken.
Used to say that a decision or action
you have just reached is are just
described as fair. Correct. Morally right.
In your opinion? Rightly so. Correct.
And then write it fully and
then rightfully so is more
means much the same as by
rights.
I Dunno.
It's your right as by rights I guess
one is correct action and then one is
within someone's rights.
I don't give a shit. Okay.
Do you want to know another funny
foreigner thing you made fun of me for?
We brought the stuff on this show,
but for 42 years of my life
[inaudible] I called it a sun visor.
You also said combative,
combative. It's combative,
combative and then Sun,
Sun visor and chewing gum
because my mother always
said fucking dive on Sango no
one says children.
I did until you pointed out that people
don't say when you were like in college
being like, I want a
piece of chewing. Yes.
My whole and nobody's
at me ever except for,
they probably thought you
were being funny. You know
like it's like your friend.
Yeah. What the fuck? I mean Shauna
is an American. I feel like Sean,
I should have been like, hey
dude, nobody says chewing gum.
Cause I would say that chewing gum
like pretending to sound that way.
You know like I just got a
piece of chewing gum but then,
cause Shauna and I would pluralize
things as much as I'm going to take this
envelope to the US postal office. Correct.
The full thing to be a dork. Yeah.
Yeah. Our trade that is Joe.
I like to put the s on that,
but I think Shauna thought you're right.
I think Shauna did think I was drinking.
Oh yeah, let's have some chewing
gums. Like we'd make fun of.
Germans had German people say
chewing gums combatitive though.
But it was all wrong. You
said it, you were like, ah,
you mean combative and then
when I pointed it out to you,
I watched your face melt.
I can't believe you couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe it.
I didn't want to believe it. I can't,
I mean again, you know I'm not,
I was raised by fucking
foreigners, man. Yeah. Oh, I
wanted to talk about something.
Oh, I'm, let me see what else I had.
Oh. Oh, here's another pronunciation.
American thing. Okay. How
do you say the word okay?
Our son likes to color
with little wax made thing.
Since what? Crayons.
Crayons. There's also cranes.
There's what? Crayons. Crayons.
Crayons. Yeah. That's not it.
I don't think so either.
I think it's crayons.
My dumb friend from Philadelphia
says tournament tournament,
so I don't,
I mean that's so I've heard the original
a tournament or a tour to go on a tour.
Yeah. What do you say?
Tour. Wait, what? A tour.
You see it tour? Yeah. What
do you say? I don't say tour.
Tour is the past tense of tear. I
tore my ligament. I'm going on tour.
I'm going on tour. Oh No. And
tour. That's foreign sounding now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. On tour. If you live
here, you say you're going on tour? No,
that's if you live in the south sea.
Your English dialect is from the south.
Because Christina, the first,
the first few years of dating,
you kept saying Christina,
you said my name like that.
Like a Hillbilly Hillbilly,
North Carolina at time?
No, no, as nim toe torn. It's,
I say tournament. It's
a Torah. A tournament.
I say tournaments as well. That's
what you're saying. Tournament. Okay.
And then you go on tour,
you go on tour, the one
tour tour. But I say tour. You
say tour? I go on tour. Oh,
come on. You don't really talk to say that
to you? Sure. I go on. I'm going on tour.
Okay. All right. Shit. Um,
I also want, oh well, okay.
I just thought I'd bring
that up. I took, uh, I, uh,
I took such a fucking
horrendous shit at JFK airport.
That's is not,
is there nothing worse than taking this
shit and an airport stall and there's
like 500 people walking past
you and talking the whole time.
It was horrific.
And I had eaten eggplant for
dinner and when I woke up at six,
6:00 AM the farts I had were
really bad and full of sulfur.
So I took a shit in the hotel and then
by the time I got to JFK I had to shit
again.
It was horrendous.
It's just hot and the cleanup was bad.
And then I had to sit on the airplane
for hours with a dirty beat. Oh.
Cause you know,
there's no bad day.
I didn't have any wipes and it was one of
those never ending wipe situations. Uh,
so, and then every time I was, I had
cough, I had a cough, you know? Yeah.
Then I cough and I piss
a little the whole time
my underwear was a disaster.
Okay. It was yellow and brown.
And is there anything you'd like
to, uh, so discuss? Oh, nasty.
You're telling me it was a
nightmare. Nasty birth. Oh my God,
you guys are so disgusting.
Well, you, um, it is, by
the way. Um, oh my God.
Seriously.
I am going to tell say this,
it was another fun year
of doing this podcast. Um,
I love doing this show.
It's really the most,
one of the most fun things I've ever done.
I love doing it with you. I love that.
We get to do this,
you're going to say you loved me.
That was how can you let me fucking
ever finish a sentence. Okay.
So I love getting to do this.
This is the best fans in all of
podcasting. Hands Down, hands down.
Thank you guys for supporting the
show and supporting us and um,
we're really looking forward to an awesome
year 2019 doing this in a new space
and I think it's going to be
really fun year of doing this show.
I hope you guys enjoy all the
things we have planned for it. Um,
but I just want to say thanks.
I hope you have a great new year.
Uh, is there a thing you want to add?
Yeah, I mean it's been a huge year.
So many things have happened, right?
Tommy? We had our second child,
there were last year. It's 2019 now. While
I'm saying this, the end of the year,
I'm recapping. It's the beginning
of the new year now. Yeah, I know,
but we didn't recap.
It's 2019.
It's two days old.
Okay. So much happened. Those, a big
waves. There was a huge year end.
We got our CBS deal. We have
fires. We had a lot of Shit, man.
A lot of stuff.
And I just want to thank everybody for
listening and I appreciate the Shit Outta
you. Comcast is always there
for me. You know me too.
And I love you guys and stay
black to real nice message.
So we'll leave on that.
Uh,
happy new year.
Nappy do hair a good one.
Here's a song from please.
Isaiah black.
Have a great new year.
We love you. Bye guys.
You can't say retarded anymore,
Connie.
Pretty strange.
Silence.
Hello?
Nosy.
I don't know.
Action.
What is your reaction?
She's unique.
She called me hours
to call me in the car.
Just don't say anything.
Yeah,
told you.